I think the test is in twickels.
Are you there? I'm on? I'm alive?
Woman! Reeling!
Good morning! Good evening! Good afternoon!
I know. I'm a whole six minutes early. What's going on? What's happening?
Isaac's a bit loud. I thought that.
You know what? I actually thought Isaac was a bit loud.
Oh my god, my controller isn't on. Of course it's not. How embarrassing.
I'm going to go into a match because I think the actual game volume is lower.
Of course we get burn in basement. Relax.
Oh my god, wait. I haven't done hardcore angels?
Wow. Terrible.
Who are you and what have you done with mommy? She's never early. I know. She's always fucking late.
Right. Updates. I've got good updates. You're going to like this.
Is Isaac still too loud?
You know what? I'll put it down again. I'll put it down a wee bit more.
So I did a community post where you can submit.
If you didn't know, I did a community post and you can literally tell me what words you want me to say or phrases.
A lot of people have given me phrases which I'm surprised about.
But I'm basically taking screenshots of what you guys are saying
and then I'm going to do like a 60, like a one hour.
The caught fish is never early nor is it too late. It will arrive safely on stream when it meets you.
God, there's how many chicks like unironically watch me. I'm getting asked.
So good girl.
I succeed. Oh, if you want to play along with it. And before I lose this and you guys are like, I'm still doing the run. Smile.
But yeah. If you want that, there's a community post.
I have officially written or sent away all the content
for the ASMR collabs I have with other creators.
Okay. It took me so long to do. I have 11 confirmed ASMR 101 collabs.
And it took me so long to get there. But I've done 11, which means when I've wrapped up, that's 11% of my freaking goals, my objectives.
So if I keep on track, I should be able to do finish my goals within a year because I wanted to do that.
I don't know if I can do the Xbox goal. That seems like a second year goal.
I'm going to be so happy because she woke up. I am God's EPS soldier right now.
But yes, I did that. I took a look into doing the clipping program.
So if you're an established clipping channel, it looks like we can basically match Idol End's offer, which is a dollar a pair of 1000 views.
A pair accepted clip channel. So that will be something that comes out in August.
The video game for a viewer is definitely looking like August, sadly.
I fucked up my artwork. I'm really upset, but I've kind of... I've done it now. I've made a mistake. I've learned from my mistakes.
So if Gen 2 and 3, if and when, do come out with a video game, they're going to be correct.
I'm very lucky that I fucked up on my specific artwork and not someone else's specific artwork.
Aces is fine, Emmys is fine, Azuras is fine, Merces is fine, Shibys is fine. It's mine I fucked up on.
So I'm really glad it was mine because mistakes were made, things were learned along the way.
But next time when it comes to animated alternative art, it's much wiser to just go to the person
that draws and animates it, not get it drawn elsewhere and then animated by someone else
because that's how things get messed up and my section is supposed to be banal,
but instead it's turned into hot dogging, but the audio I recorded is for banal and I don't know what to do.
I think I'm going to leave my original audio type in, but unfortunately the artwork doesn't match the section correctly.
So yeah, that's my update about my section in the video game.
But look, mistakes happen and I will say, I have learned so much and I'm so happy that I could even learn...
I can even learn to commission a video game, I know it sounds silly but...
But yeah, is there a scene where it works properly?
So yes, everyone has an animated scene, but my type is banal but the animation is hot dogging
because that was a mistake on my part.
The animator didn't know that he was supposed to make it disappear.
Hocus pocus.
But anyway, I messed up, but look, lessons learned, things have happened.
I had a cute night with my dad, he wanted to watch me play meccosal and I was like, oh god, oh god.
Because I was like, what did I see in the stream?
But we actually did see him watch it and it wasn't that bad.
I honestly wasn't that bad that stream, I could have been way worse.
But he was like, oh my god, I remember all that and I'm like, oh yeah.
I showed him, he was freaking laughing at me.
I showed him the map where he watched the meccosal, we watched it together, we didn't watch Star Trek last night.
And he did what?
Oh excuse me, how are we on today?
Pardon me, boys.
I was like, I don't know if you just remember the snow map where you had to blow up the generator
and then all the friend Lee's turn hostile because you were actually hidden.
And I was trying to blow up the bridge and he was like, oh, that weapon's not going to do anything against that bridge.
And I'm like, how am I supposed to know that?
I'm going to make, it's giving me missiles.
Of course I'm going to use the freaking missiles and he's like laughing at my terrible freaking thingy.
And I was panicking and he was like, you know what, you actually are a wee bit entertaining.
I'm like, excuse you, I'm a bit entertaining.
Like give me some credit because he was like, oh that was actually kind of funny.
And I was like, yeah, so like if a dad calling you, literally call me a noob and I'm like, excuse you.
I was like, not even, I probably couldn't even speak when I first consumed the game.
Like, yeah, just to be that, right?
Because we were talking about content creators in general because I showed them more of the VTubers
and I showed them what the girls were doing, what I do.
And I said like, if you play a game that a refund really enjoys, like it's more entertaining.
Like it has so much more factor because if I had to watch a streamer play Viva Punyatta
or play, you know, Hell Divers 2, well I have a nostalgic bonus when it comes to Viva Punyatta.
Shame my daughter is a noob. I am forsaken. Why am I forsaken?
But he wants to play the game so I think my PC is getting stolen after this stream.
But it was fantastic.
Yes, I do apologize to anyone who is looking forward to the ASMR.
This is where the bad announcements begin.
We hate you, strongy, bad announcements.
I cannot do ASMR for three weeks.
Nor can I do any type of membership stream for three weeks.
However, as always, I will make it up instantly when my me pops goes away way again.
So today's ASMR has been swapped out.
But yes, there will be no ASMR plans for three weeks, there will be no thingy.
However, my gen mates are always doing ASMR.
Mercy did a fantastic ASMR stream yesterday called You Are My Pet POV.
Anarch, you're so stinky.
Boo. Thank you for the tip, Anarch.
Literally, this is the boooove ones. You suck, strong, boo.
Okay, for the updates on everyone's Patreon, today everyone's Patreon will have at least one audio out.
There is a bit of a...
Try to phrase it nicely so it doesn't sound like an arsehole, but I do want to explain the situation.
There is a bit of a traffic jam, if you will, in production because some talents got a bit distracted
and forgot they had to record on top of streaming.
And it caused a bit of a traffic jam.
So today, by the end of today, this stream, I will be editing for myself in Azura.
There should be a Mercy and a AC.
And Shibi and Emi should already have uploads because they are done.
Okay, I have it.
Literally, the girls got a wee bit carried away and I was like, hey guys, remember that time we did Patreon
and it's like your main source of income.
Please, please, it takes 15 minutes.
15 minutes, please record.
So it's a bit of a traffic jam, but it should be resolved by the end of this week.
So, yeah.
Understandable games are...
Yes, thank you for no one being annoyed at them.
But yes, at the end of the day, I will ensure that there is an audio for everyone at least one up.
And level up.
Okay.
And then take 15 minutes forever later.
Ah.
I love them.
I'm like, girls, please.
Now, they're still in my batch of scripts and I know my batch of scripts takes 15 minutes to record and you know more.
And I'm like, come on, baby girls, come on.
I'm like rubbing the lamp.
I'm like, come on, genie, you come, you come.
I'm like begging them, please, please, I want my knees.
But yes.
Thank you for your patience.
Apologies for the wait.
But again, after today, at least one will be up and then it will smooth out and be like,
there's two out by the 14.
Roughly.
I can't remember what everyone's upload date is, to be honest.
It's all over the shop.
But next month, I plan on having dates along with their schedules.
You know how they posted that funny haha schedule?
That...
Oh, it's not an ASMR stream.
My apologies.
No, I can't do ASMR for three weeks.
My gen mates at any point are doing ASMR.
Emmy is doing ASMR this week when she returns.
She's actually done a membership script writing.
We lurking to be like, hmm, is this how you write scripts?
I mean, this is how I write scripts.
I mean, it's just pure paper.
Pure paper.
Okay, I'm a...
You can always rub my lamp instead.
Go over here.
I'm going to slurp my tea, okay?
And then we'll get into a cane.
So you can actually see cane stats to the left.
He has 1.3 movement speed, which is fantastic.
And his damage is a bit harder.
That 4.2 damage.
Not bad, believe it.
And he has 1% luck.
So luck doesn't affect things like the Gambo machines.
What it affects is drop rate.
So we have an item, that little foot you see on my stuff.
We have a little item called Lucky Foot,
which means one, our luck is added by one.
And two, it means we can huff pills,
and they will be positive.
Now, there is a few pills that are positive in quotation marks
that aren't really.
An example of that is One Makes You Vigor.
It increases your hitbox, but it's considered a good pill.
But it means you can't lose stats via pills, basically.
Hi, Strawny.
With her father-in-law, I'm guessing there won't be a new
Patreon recording session.
I've already recorded my three audios.
I need to edit the script for the fourth that we wrote together.
And then, that's all for this month.
So don't worry, my Patreon.
I'm a smart bean.
I did a few things in advance,
because I knew how much of a numpty I was going to be, okay?
It also affects some item ability proc rates.
Yes, that too.
That is a very big note.
If you see in the bottom left,
it looks like I have a little paper clip in the corner.
I can open gold chests for free.
I do not require a key.
Three One Makes You Vigor should give you a transformation, though.
Yeah.
It's just that amazing.
Yeah, I knew I had to spam ahead, if you will.
Right, I'm slurping my tea.
The tea has been slurped.
Wow, Cain was built for a looting.
Yeah, so we're not playing Tainted Cain.
Tainted Cain has this thing called Loot Bag,
where you can take eight items.
Isaac's still a bit loud.
Goddamn, Isaac, calm down.
I was really, actually,
that was one thing about the Microsoft stream.
My dad was like, wait, you didn't test the audio.
And I'm like, fucking stop annihilating me.
Oh my gosh, not all streamers are perfect.
I was getting absolutely roasted by my dad on my stream,
and I'm like, I've already told him how much I made in my first month.
I'm going to let it be a surprise when the short comes out
how much I made in my first month,
but I was like, I'm fucking annihilated.
I'm like, back off.
Get off me.
What's up?
Hi, Stranny.
Hi, everyone.
Are you excited?
Immers is coming back.
Your dad's a pro stream critic.
You're perfect roasted by dad.
Everything is shining.
Did he get shocked when the helicopter scene showed the audio peak?
Well, he was...
So we were at the waterfall,
and he was reading chat.
He was reading you guys,
and he was like, oh, they're really nice to you.
Because you play so badly.
I was like, all right, dad.
Fuck's sake, man.
But I was like, yeah.
So that's what chat is considered about.
I was like saying that.
I got asked reflins, but people say chat.
And he's lurking.
Literally, he was reading you.
And he was like, oh, everyone's so nice to you.
And I'm like, yeah.
And he was like...
So obviously, I was telling the stories about, like,
my dad used to play multiplayer in the water on Atlas.
And he was like, oh, you remember, you remember.
And I'm like, yeah, dad, you never stop talking to me about it.
Every time I bring up, like, Xbox.
Was he expecting us to treat you like an enemy on Xbox Live?
Oh, well, I was talking about, like,
how Xbox used to have open mic in those games.
And I was like, oh, people would play music.
They'd spam the N word down the mic.
All of that.
And he was like, oh, that's right.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
And I'm like, yep.
That's because it happened in Call of Duty when I played.
Well, is there a chance Papa Kottos is lurking?
Well, he's not reading.
Right now he's asleep.
I can hear the walls vibrate, which vibrate.
Vibrate of vibration, which is why we can't do it anymore.
But there is a chance he might watch this and be like,
what did you do today?
Because he finds it fascinating.
He's like, how did you earn that much money?
And I was like, oh, like, I believe in consistency.
I believe in an exchange of goods and services.
I was like explaining, like, we are being observed.
Yes.
I was explaining to him, like, the way I like to say thank you
is I like to provide more content.
So I have a disclaimer in my short that says how much I earned.
Basically, it's over 10K.
Because you guys are stupendously supportive.
But yeah, in my first month of strong calls,
I made over $10,000.
Because you guys are fucking insane.
I also break down the income via Patreon, stream elements,
and what I earned on YouTube.
Nothing you don't deserve.
I find it hard to accept.
I'm going to be honest.
That is a...
You know how, like, people were like, oh,
we need to support her more.
You give me more than enough.
We're funding Gen2.
Look, my Donathon is an October 10th.
At this rate, the Donathon end of goal is going to be like
$5,000 Gen2 production confirmed at this rate.
I'm going to be honest.
You will accept her money and you're going to like it.
Well, at least let me fucking get some ASMR in exchange.
And you were worried about funding Gen2.
Literally, I'm not being funny.
Originally, my Gen2 goal was going to be like
I think $15,000 US was my end goal.
And I would have things all the way.
And at the end, it would be like Gen2 confirmed production.
Motherfucker, I'm going to do it with like $300 at this rate.
VTuber community support.
It's actually insane.
It's genuinely insane.
Some had a year of build up.
I couldn't hold it.
This is terrible.
She said she was supported enough time to support her.
No, seriously.
So I broke down the income, but I had to see a few disclaimers.
My disclaimers, like, I stream every single day.
I can't remember my other ones.
But I did have disclaimers.
And then at the end, I was like,
I remember to hold 30% for tax purposes.
Like, I sounded so depressed at the end.
You deserve it.
You're basically a comfort streamer for all good.
Even with my wee accent.
Yeah, am I your comfort streamer putting you to sleep?
My only gripe is having to pay 5 or 10% of that taxes to the company.
You beat 10% taxes.
What country do you live in, Luxembourg?
10%?
What the fuck?
I'm, like, 30%.
Hmm.
Accent's part of why I come back every day.
You're like that.
And then, see, that accent is getting you 10K.
I don't think that I'm not being funny.
My Donaldson goal is not going to be 10K at this rate.
Like, the end goal, you know how it's like,
oh, my goal has been achieved.
Right, here's extended.
No.
I have put in a plushy request for a certain MILF goddess.
Goddess of fertility.
Pardon my French, not MILF.
I have put in a request about a plushy for a bleeding heart.
So I'm going to see what the response is.
And depending on that, we either do a different business
or see what happens, I don't know.
But I am starting to mildly prepare for Azur's donathon.
Her birthday donathon starts and immediately ends.
I'm not being funny, but I'm starting to think
that's what's going to happen.
I don't want to predict the future,
but I'm getting nervous for how little the actual end goal is.
It's going to be, like, Gen 2 production confirmed.
$69.
There you go.
When is Azur's birthday?
The 21st of August.
Now, I know I'm being a bit pre-emptive,
but a month and a week and two weeks and a...
Just change the goal at Gen 3 while you're at it.
Honestly, at this rate.
Hmm.
Just add more goals then.
Thankfully, I do have very good stretch goals,
which I think everyone's going to be quite happy with.
I am focusing on more public access things.
Maybe, you know, free.
Actually, that reminds me, I need to edit so much for Twitter.
I'll turn it off.
And...
And I've got a Bible movement inside me.
Stretch goals.
Quite literally.
Yeah.
The rest goes to the shareholders.
Hmm, yes, we have shareholders.
Anyway, done with the high table while we're at it.
Okay, I have hydration.
Hmm.
The community posts in the community-related videos are quite good, yes.
It's my first one doing it.
I was like, I want to do a 60-minute, like, triggers.
So I'm going to take screenshots of the ones that I want to see.
Now, I don't want anyone being...
Having a sorbuti, because I've no peggio for one.
But then you have a sorbuti if I didn't pick the phrase or thing you've asked me.
It's not like it's the only one I'm going to be doing, okay?
Hello, America Hiya!
You're my goal and I want to straight...
That's terrible.
She says one of her goals is literally a figurine.
That's a tentacle.
Can we be a bit mean with the phrases?
Yes, most certainly.
I have absolutely no issues with that.
Okay, so we are lovely cane.
No, we're not going to do boss rush.
I'm just going to talk through it.
So you can actually see we have a lucky foot pixel on our right foot.
See how it's like a bit red?
We've got a sacrifice room, which no, we are not messing with.
But there is a chance the fires can drop a cheeky coin for us.
Cane is smooth like butter.
We did pick about one a wee coin.
You also have the best drink ever.
Good smile collab when steady on.
I think we need a wee bit more numbers now.
I'm not much of a number whole bag,
but I have to admit when it comes to contacting companies like that,
I kind of need the...
Oh God, these blow up.
Oh no.
Okay, I am not good at Isaac.
So if I could just get Godhead, that would be...
I don't even think I've unlocked Godhead.
You know, there's so many items I've yet to unlock.
But yes, we're just having a chill day on Isaac.
I get to nerd about it because I love it.
And I can't wait to play multiplayer Isaac with you.
See these spiders?
See you.
One shot, yeah.
Oh, and it unlocks a new spider.
Just to really upset me, yeah.
I am taking damage in unclear room,
grants flight,
spectral tears,
stops time greatly increases speed and fire rate.
I mean, we have to take damage to activate it,
but I mean, it's better than nothing.
Okay, we'll grab this.
Godhead.
Cast the gate that enemies with the Godhead.
I keep forgetting you can slowly move if you're on a controller.
Oh yeah, I'm a controller.
I'm not moving.
Oh, you didn't see that.
No, that's it.
Wait, why is it so small?
Why can't I make it bigger?
No, I feel like manual...
Oh my God.
No, don't.
This is embarrassing.
I like...
Stop.
I like accidentally minimized it.
It won't let it go big.
Stop.
That's so embarrassing.
It won't let it go big again.
Get big.
What are you doing?
Oh my God.
Right.
Hold on.
That's actually so embarrassing.
Okay, that's the best I can do.
I don't know how I managed that,
but what's done is done.
Press F.
Alt return to full...
Alt return.
Stop.
I'll actually believe you.
But the heck is return?
Return isn't a button on the keyboard.
Oh my God, it is F.
The reeflings told the truth.
The reeflings loved me.
They didn't tell me to Alt F4.
Hold on.
Yay.
Thank you, reefling.
Who said Alt?
Alt owner.
Look at you.
I actually being nice to you.
What the heck?
See, other streamer communities
would have trolled the fuck.
I'm like, uh, uh, uh, actually panicking.
Oh, I don't like those guys.
I don't like burning basement.
Actually, well, I'm at it.
I don't like any enemies in Isaac
because they're all meanie-boo beanies.
Please don't jump into the fire.
Because when he jump into the fire,
he gets higher and higher.
Can we get much higher and higher?
Stay.
No, we don't need that.
What we got?
We got useless.
We don't even have enough for it.
And it's an unidentified film.
Not even Larry Junior?
I don't know.
I hate this, the sailors,
because it fills spiders.
Otherwise, other ways for sure.
But I like that.
What do you mean?
We never billy or troll you forever.
Okay, this isn't actually the worst jewel.
I'm kind of wanting to get rid of the baby guy first
because he's a bit of a headache.
Oh, it's not going to happen.
It's not going to happen.
It's fine.
Watch me get...
Yeah, unfortunately, when he gets untethered,
he has quite interesting physics,
which I don't like going off against.
I don't know, maybe we can just do that.
Are you joking me?
The one thing I didn't want was to go against him.
Empty heart.
Taking damage as a chance to spawn a red heart.
Okay, hold on.
Now, we could maybe get insanely...
Oh my god, it's a wake-up.
We could maybe get insanely,
insanely lucky on these sacrificial spikes.
Due to old vantage, has a chance to spawn hearts.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
And then we have two hearts back here.
So you'll notice we pee now at the door.
When your health is hidden,
that will tell you if you're in trouble or not.
So we're peeing because we have a half a heart.
So we're going to pick up these double hearts here.
Yummy, yummy, juicy, juicy.
What?
Aww.
Why does the message only say faces on screen?
I'll make you change that.
Thank you very much to me, Tim Schottel.
Thank you.
For your kind tip.
I appreciate it.
Does that actually mean...
We got a sack?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that was actually a really good story.
Oh, and we got a heart back.
Come on, surely we'll get an S tier item.
Literally S tier.
And we got a heart back.
Oh my god, we're actually doing so good.
What do I need to do?
Do I need to sacrifice that wee guy?
I think so.
I think I'm going to have to sacrifice that heart.
You know that?
Okay, we're not...
Oh no, it's behind this.
Oh, I wouldn't have done that had I known.
And seeing Gamble luck, I thought it was going to drop.
I just realized we can probably just...
die in this room.
If one of the bombs ricochet...
Oh god, get me out, get me out, right.
Safe, safe, safe.
Right, what's the card?
Teleports Isaac to the shop, sure.
Okay, we are going to...
Oh no, we don't have enough health.
Oh, I shouldn't have picked that up.
I could have bought one from the shop.
You know that?
What have I done?
You have to kill me.
I'm going to kill you.
What have I done?
You have to kill an angel.
No, you can actually...
There's not a heart in the shop.
Are you serious?
If we do not get Gibbon...
a heart when we stand on the spike,
I don't think we can pick up our reward.
We need a heart to draw.
I literally...
Alright, bye.
Are you serious?
We need...
We need a smithereen of a heart.
We're going to have to actually buy that card in the shop
and hope it's the lover's card,
which gives us two red hearts.
I have been trolled.
The super secret room, maybe.
I mean, we'll pop it.
Oh, I knew the secret room was there.
Alright, hold on.
I'm doing it from this side, though.
Please have something in it for me.
No.
It's just money.
So where's the other room?
Is it down here?
I thought it might be here or there.
I don't like this map play out.
I hate when the maps...
I mean, it could be an elbow.
Which is here.
We'll only have one bomb left.
Buy the pill.
Maybe it's a full health.
I can't believe we did all the sacrificing for nothing.
Come on, pill.
Tears up.
I mean...
It's alright.
Oh, that's so unlucky.
What shop doesn't have a freaking heart?
And there's no heart that dropped here.
There could be something behind here.
Money.
Not what we wanted.
Super secret room isn't next to any other room.
Yeah, it can be, can't it?
Gamble over.
I believe in the sack luck.
There'll be nothing inside that we can utilize.
Yeah, a bomb and a key.
That is so unlucky.
Wait, is that actual?
Not me learning that Super Secret Room only has one connected to it.
Well, then it can't be elbow.
It has to be like one of these weird ones here.
My guess is opposite of the shop.
We're doing it once.
I don't want to waste my bombs.
Well, I've wasted my bomb.
I can't believe that.
We were one away from greatness.
Oh well.
We tried, we tried.
We can maybe do a bit better on the next floor, okay?
Womp, womp, womp.
Terrible luck.
I should feel ashamed of myself for how terrible that luck was.
Shops, treasure rooms and boss rooms don't count as rooms.
Great grandpa.
Okay, we're just going to pop the hermit then now.
Because normally we do get spawned in.
God, what a trinket now.
Again, there's no healing in here.
The game where it's like, oh god, I really need to not mess up
or this is going to lose my run.
Okay.
Got a bomb back from him.
Okay, hopefully there's something good in this suite.
Oh, there is a chest here we can get into for free.
We just need to sacrifice a bomb for it.
I know, I know you're like, oh, strong eight,
where did you get these MLG skills?
I know, I'm just so good at Isaac.
What do you mean I get super lucky?
And the only reason I win runs is because I get like,
I love Spoonbender.
It's my favorite item.
Because you don't have to aim.
I love Spoonbender.
We got a cheeky heart.
Let's see what's in here.
Slows down enemies, deals 10 damage.
I mean, it's a fill room damage.
We don't even have an active item.
Right, we're going to pop this.
Is there a tenant rock?
Hey mom, hi broly legend.
We've got started.
We're doing...
I was actually lucky.
Okay, now we have tons of keys.
Just like that.
We are playing...
Isaac Kane,
and we can huff pills on Kane.
We love Casting Spills.
I hate...
I hate when the enemies do that.
Sorry.
Someone's getting the boot.
We got two pills though.
Luck.
Experimental HP up.
See, where were you when we needed you most?
Hmm?
Could have used my ultimate.
Spoon, Bender and Brimstone.
Oh yeah, that's exactly what I like.
Thank you broly legend for the fine.
You missed it, but I was talking about
how supportive the reeflings are
and how my...
God, it's because my luck is so high.
Now we have an increased rate for chest drops,
which gives multiple items.
I don't know if I want to go in there yet.
What, we got 100% Devil Deal?
I don't know if we're doing Devil Deal.
Phew, you cheeky cheekerton.
I prefer the Angel Deal
because you don't have to sacrifice anyhow.
Ooh.
Devil's Isaac's Coins.
Ooh, okay, okay, okay.
What was in the shop again? Was it anything of value?
No.
One luck, double it in that.
Shops aren't being very kind to me today.
Brim is the Devil item though.
No, but...
What happens if I got Sacred Heart though?
Smile.
Oh come on, don't...
I hate these guys when they hide behind rocks.
You know what you're doing, eh?
Yeah, exactly, as soon as I get closer to it.
What does it do?
Freaking jumps closer to the screen.
That's right.
You're done for.
Get rekt, get rekt.
I knew it, I knew it.
Probably Isaac's.
Um...
Another hermit, surprisingly enough.
Sacred Heart is better.
Breath of life incoming.
Stop, if that's my first item.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Uh...
Steady on.
Oh god, my analogue stick's kinda...
Gonna look funny.
Bomba, no tinted rock.
Get rid of that.
See what you're gonna draw behind you.
Okay, that's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Right, so because there's nothing here,
it makes me think, oh no, I can't be here.
What the heck are the secret rooms in this map?
Down, straight down.
Elbow maybe?
And then one here?
Yeah, okay.
We're gonna...
Now you can get pills from...
From the mushrooms, so I think I am gonna
spend some bombs on these.
Yes, that's what we wanted.
I'm drowsy, no, oh no, I don't...
Ah, right, what a waste.
Draft, draft, double draft, but it's fine.
It's fine, you can't win them all, smile.
Hopefully we'll get a key beggar.
Slow down.
What? What kind of room is this?
Oh, hold on, let's pop this right now.
Yes, we definitely would like a slow down effect,
I say, as the or is already sped up.
You were like slow for a millisecond, please.
I don't have the tears or benefit of any of this yet.
I literally have like super passive items.
The only reason we have a stat up is because of...
What's it called?
Because of...
Pills.
Because we have astral projection,
which it gets me a thing if I get damaged.
Lucky bandage is passive and so is lucky key.
Oh, please, just perish.
Actually, I will say one thing I like about the monster design.
If you look at this monster, he has a cleft palate,
which is when your little schnozer in your mouth connect.
You can get it fixed in surgery, it's not a big deal.
But I like that the designs are quite...
There's quite a few diagnoses that turned into bosses,
which I think is pretty cool.
I mean, I thought it was pretty cool.
Oh god, I'm so tempted to go inside.
Ruffer's floor, little monstero, yay.
But there is quite a few...
I'll take the diamond card with me so we can double our money.
I know I should have done the cursed room,
but I had terrible luck last time.
I'd rather sacrifice my health on...
On a...
Oh, yeah, fuck him up, fuck him up, yeah.
Take that, take that.
All right, so I get to keep this.
I'm just losing all my health.
I'm just losing my health, I don't want it.
I didn't want my health anyway, I didn't need it.
I'm going to lose my angel deal because of this twat.
Oh, goodness' sake.
That was terrible.
Sorry, I really am just terrible at the game.
I'm just popping this right now because I don't trust myself.
Yeah, that's...
I'm going to need the shops to help me out with something.
Give me, like, champions belt, damage up.
I'll take that.
Black candle...
Does that give me a damage up?
Give me a damage up and avoid curses?
I think so.
Money!
Boss rush this time?
No, you ain't getting it.
You excited for the next Ed McMuffin game?
It's called Mugenics.
I saw gameplay footage of it.
I'll be interested to see if it will...
Oh, I don't want to take the full heart yet.
I'll stay half heart in case there's a sacrifice room.
Mugenics looks interesting.
I'm not sure how much I...
I'm going to enjoy it.
It is a perplexing game.
From the stuff that I've seen of it.
I don't know how the mushrooms work, I'm going to be honest.
I don't know if he's going to do a diagonal.
I do have time to react though, so I can get out of the way.
I hope it's multiplayer.
Think big, find chaos in the shop.
Wild card.
A little bit cheeky chaos.
I'm going to play it safe.
This guy really...
You shouldn't really be taking damage from him once you know what's up.
I'm just playing mega safe because I lost all my hearts
and I really want to get an angel deal.
He just perished him.
He's like, I've had enough.
A large bomb.
Well, we'll touch it anyway,
but I think it actually prefers slowing.
The large bomb would help with the enemy though.
I don't have flay and before it drops like a coin.
I don't have flay.
Give me...
Yeah, I was going to say counterfeit penny.
I don't have flay.
Maybe I'll get flay in a sec.
If I do actually win this smile.
Right, I beg, give me something good.
You didn't see it,
but I just violently put my head backwards out of annoyance.
Well, this bomb in exchange of seven is worth it,
so we'll grab that.
Wait, use it to become flying.
Refling?
Can I teleport you into my brain right now?
Oh my God.
Why are you so smart?
Why?
Okay.
The question is, do we take counterfeit penny or not?
Did we do it?
Did we go out on economy?
Yes.
Because we have a good drop rate.
We're doing economy.
I should have picked that up first, idiot.
Anyway.
Right, grab this first.
And then we'll go back to this.
Refling, you're so smart.
Right, we're going to pop our diamonds.
So boom, we've got 48 coins just like that.
We are going to pick up the cards
because we might get a hierophant.
Ooh.
Ooh, we got the justies.
Okay, we'll just go full health over that.
Spawn's a blood donation.
Teleports Isaac to the first floor,
and then we'll just do angel deal to get it.
We got holy man.
Oh my Lord.
I don't know if I can beat up this angel.
I don't think I have the strength to beat him up,
but we have holy man.
Oh, we'll come back and beat up the angels at a later date.
What we got?
Blood donation machine.
I'm going to see if there's a sacrifice one.
It doesn't look like there is,
but we might be able to get a sugar ton of money.
Please don't do that.
Money.
Please stop jumping around the map.
You're scaring me.
Wah.
Now you can go into the curse room for free.
You are so right bestie.
So I never realized this stuff until you type it out.
I'm sure there are tumors that can maximize.
Isaac runs down to every little detail.
Me, I'm like, oh yeah, you can do that.
Can you?
Yeah.
Right.
Let's go grab.
I think we'll pop blood donation machine as well.
This is why we don't do the curse room.
I'm kind of tempted, but I don't want to...
If we get back in the angel room,
I'll take that as a sign that we are supposed to jump in.
We are not taking curse before.
And I was like, oh, why don't you take curse today?
Do you need to take curse?
No.
Okay, let's pop this one.
Two, three, four.
And then grab that and then one, two.
Oh, we did get a bandage prop.
Oh, there we go.
That's what we want.
We want the...
We want the bandage train.
Well, someone please think of the bandages.
We might be able to get blood at IV bag.
If we get IV bag, we're in the money
because IV puts off our speed.
Here we go for it, I think so.
Oh, there you go.
I think we're going to go and roll for IV bag
because it puts our speed up and gives us another health slot.
What did you call me?
Yeah, that's right.
I called you that.
We're also going to put money in the donation machine in general
because that will raise our floor luck.
Okay, I stick.
There we go.
Yeah, you better start proking.
Shawnee breaking the economy feels good, man.
I became the very thing I swore to destroy.
Oh, come on, pop.
Oh, no, no, this can't be.
Right, we're going to grab this health.
We're at 84 economy.
Don't mind if I do.
Shawnee, this is a lot.
Weezer build?
Are you making fun of my build?
Getting billy though.
Right, we don't have anything else we can really utilize.
Tell for Isaac.
Right, first things first.
We'll just double the bombs now.
Get out of the way.
Bunk and then do that.
And then buy you the world.
It's probably better using on the next floor.
We're going to put away some money so we can increase our luck
and angel deal per chance.
Or we'll just jam it and get nothing.
Not like I wanted anything anyway.
Right, four.
What do we need?
We've got eight key.
I mean, we have plenty.
We'll keep the world for next.
You already have Nightmare Penny in the shop.
Yes, I've done that before already.
And then I blew it up.
We'll just bomb this because we can't donate into it anymore,
but we can get the monies out of it.
Now, our great chance fight for the shop does go up exponentially.
Okay, wait.
So what is here?
Okay.
That was gamer sense before.
And it was like, are you?
There was a poop in here then.
All time we could have got IV bag.
We could have fully healed.
We could have fully healed, but did we?
No.
Yeah, no.
Of course, I destroyed the machine before finding the room.
Okay.
What is it?
Versus pestilence.
So unfortunately, we don't get what is considered a normal boss kind of item.
I really hope the shop is going to start giving us something that helps with fights
because unfortunately, our item rooms, they haven't been lacking too much.
As I said, the angel deal came in close.
Oh, it's not got ahead when she keeps on sucking.
You'll lose your hit.
That's not how anatomy works at all.
We are going to play it careful.
I really...
Again, as I said, if we do unlock the angel room again, I'm going to blow one up.
But it actually is in our best interest to lose this angel percentage
because we've already snuck inside and got the item.
Motherfucker.
Okay, we're going in.
Right.
Get rid of the fire first because that's such a health hazard.
And then we gift a this.
Now, if this goes well...
Oh, there's a thing there as well.
If this goes well, we can actually fully unlock the key.
Now, I do have a mod that lets me see where they're going to fire
because I'm not good enough to not have it.
I ain't that good.
I'm not that guy.
Trust me.
We could potentially take on the second angel as well and get the key.
So we get two key pieces that will maximize our drop.
We are just playing it safe.
We did get hit.
So unfortunately, my holy mantle is gone, but that's okay.
As I said, it's not too bad.
I mean, it's alright.
I would like to keep our eternal heart.
That's what that white heart.
If we make it to the next level with it, we will get to keep a whole new red heart.
So again, oh, he's red.
Oh, he's raging.
Slow down, mate.
Slow down.
Right.
You're getting bombed.
Honestly.
Okay.
Well, completely missed.
Oh, no.
I fucked up.
Bruh.
Stop.
Oh, my God.
I'm actually going to, I'm going to lose this, please.
I would like to remain alive.
I would like to remain well.
Please get bombed.
Oh, my God.
The bomb hardly does anything.
Sorry.
I am severe.
I'm starting to need startups.
Yeah, I can see the need for the startups.
Please stop this madness.
Stop it.
You're spawning in too many babies.
Okay.
It's fine.
We did it.
We just need to take out this baby.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
We now have increased our angel deal as much as we can outwith like blowing up the shopkeepers,
for example.
The angel think you're going to produce gen2?
Exactly.
Unconfirmed?
No, we're not doing angel.
I'm tempted to go grab that chest.
I don't know if it's the wisest thing.
I mean, surely with holy mantle and I'm not going to mess it up so badly.
Surely.
And we could get something out of it.
We're going to do it.
Send it.
Let's see what we're working with.
Okay.
That wasn't bad.
I just need to not mess up now.
Focus.
Concentrate.
Concentration.
Patient.
Okay.
We're going to pop that on these guys because they like to run at you.
Yeah.
That's right.
I'm on to you.
Mm-hmm.
That's great.
You're doing shrapnel.
I've got these guys.
Okay.
One more phase.
Oh, I'm just serious.
That's the one thing I could perish this game for.
It's like, oh, let me just blow them up.
Let me just spawn them on your face and I'm like, no, please don't do that.
That's not very nice.
Oh, please stop spawning flies.
Bro, I ain't got bombs to deal with them.
I really don't want to lose my little spiral spiral spirit heart.
It's not spirit heart either.
Soul heart.
I didn't.
I mean, we actually didn't come away any worse.
I'm catching up at 1.5 speeds.
Sorry.
You don't understand how many buttons you add the rest of the other hit.
I've been left, of course, restoring all the money.
Oh, lol.
I think I could stand myself at 1.5.
She's becoming Neo and dodging every bullet.
How is this still open?
Normally like shots.
Yeah, I was going to say normally shots like that.
I hate these guys.
Even worse if their brother who spawns 20 million yellow jump inspired.
Oh, I hate these booters.
GG.
Look.
Momathon.
No risk, no reward.
Oh, we got a chest.
And before there's nothing in it.
I'm going to pop the world card just so we know it's up ahead.
That's not bad.
If we get a trinket to swallow, then...
Oh, we've got a library.
That's not bad.
Oh, why is it the diagonal?
Oh, I hate the diagonal ones.
They're so bad.
Please.
Right, everyone's getting popped right now.
I've had enough of yous.
Everyone's getting popped.
Right, we'll do the secret room and then we'll go to the library.
Because if we can get double shot, that should increase our DPS by a bit of considerable output.
Okay.
I'm going to hopefully get a bomb out of this.
We might come back for that trinket.
That's not a bad...
That is not a bad trinket at all.
Not a bad trinket for what we have.
Not bad at all.
The odds of the shop having...
I'm just going to pop that.
And it spawned blue spiders for us.
The astronomical...
I'm going to take HP.
Yep.
I just knew I should have saved it for this room.
I could have seen it was a big room.
I knew I was taking damage.
These bats are terrible.
I think they're called zoo bats in game.
I know Pokemon zoo bats.
Yes, I know.
Please, three books.
Close enough and you come.
Oh, wait.
We just got the angel deal on purpose.
But that gives us infinite health.
I think...
I think we're swapping teams already.
It didn't take as long.
Oh, it's Sissy the spider.
Hi, Sissy.
Look at the cute little blue spider.
That sounded like a silverback gorilla came up behind you and squeezed all the air.
I already popped.
Your vods are the only ones I've watched at normal speed since you said they spent time is more important than watching the entire vod.
Yeah, YouTube's so annoying.
I'm literally tempted by the devil unironically.
I want to pop it so we have full health.
That's terrible.
And I just got the angel deal as well.
Oh well.
I prefer playing safer with full health than anything else.
So please forgive I am a bad...
Oh, well, that can have gone any worse.
Please, I hope this shop has something decent inside.
I'm...
Or the item room.
I'll take the item room out.
Oh, Sissy drops me spiders.
Is that a bomba?
Are you a bomba?
Well, we do have a chance to do mega satan if things go in our favor.
Whether or not they will, that's different, but you never know.
Right.
Good item.
Are you joking?
No, not Keynes.
Oh, yuck.
My own eye is back.
Entering a new floor has a chance.
I wish I really need a swallow pill.
I need to swallow the trinkets.
Oh, it's not a greed fight, but it's absolutely rubbish.
You should be ashamed of yourself.
What's this?
The Emperor challenge mode.
What is with these shops?
What's that?
Five plus bombs.
I mean, 15 quid for five bombs isn't terrible.
I'll swap out for it and I'm going to see what this pill is all about.
Because we've not discovered it.
Please be a swallow...
pheromones.
Okay, thanks for wasting my money.
Money.
Yeah.
I'll give it to the judgment.
He's giving me bombs.
We do have enough money to go around.
Yeah.
It's fine.
I didn't want...
It's not like I wanted a billion trinkets anyway.
I think the secret room's below us right now.
Because look at...
See how flat the wall is.
Yeah.
You can...
Right, we are going to bomb these skulls because there's a chance we get...
I said there's a chance we get a black heart from them,
but no, no, all of them were like not...
Right.
Obviously, I've used the keys already to get in the rooms.
We've got the hearts for devil deals.
Don't say it.
Don't make a flat joke.
Look.
You know what?
Speaking of flat.
Gen 2.
That's right.
Get your facts right.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I'm dying.
But yes.
I do have a short.
That reveals how much I earned coming out soon.
Arissa's been fantastic to work with.
She's actually about to do a batch for Sheebie.
I think management's about to do a tweet asking for more Ed tours.
Because we're kind of sitting about twiddling our thumbs,
waiting for other people,
and it's like the contents, they're ready to be edited.
We're just waiting.
And obviously, shorts are very important for the growth of...
Oh my God, Sissy is kind of getting it.
Sorry, Sissy's doing so well right now.
Right, we can't go into the curse for free.
So, if you have Ed in...
Do we want?
If we do read,
then we just focus on getting devil deals now.
Speaking of that, how is Emmy?
Emmy's coming home, didn't you know?
She's actually got a stream.
She's so excited to stream again.
She's like missed her big brother so much.
And before I know it's like,
that's weird, you're playing into that.
Fuck you.
People enjoy things consensually.
Fucking relax, okay?
Right, I'm going to bomb him.
Oh, I haven't got money.
We are going to get a devil deal,
a bit of a devil deal.
We're going to keep the book on our persons.
I like it because I like planes to proceed
with like infinite health respawn.
Do we keep?
I think actually, you know what we're going to pick up?
We are going to pick up the restock trinket.
And we're going to say goodbye to counterfeit penny.
You've done fantastic.
You've absolutely boosted our economy out the wazoo.
But now that we have 4% luck,
our drop rate is high enough to enjoy what it's worth.
Play into your gen mates theme, thinking.
How dare...
Motherfucker, I created Emmy in that image.
I'm sorry, I see this again.
Emmy is created in my image.
If I had a lighter voice, it would be over for you fuckers.
It would...
How did I already get hit?
Was I not paying attention?
God, I really need some devil,
good devil items to come through.
She's like everything I want to be.
Small, cute, adorable, absolutely outrageous, yes.
But I don't have a light voice, so I can't do that.
Unless you guys want like...
Was it the gap mo?
I remember when you guys taught me what gap mo means.
I was like gap mo, huh?
What does that mean?
Unless you want the gap mo to be astronomical,
and we just end up getting a lollipop version of me.
And I still sound the exact same.
My voice doesn't change at all.
I'm just like, who goes, how's it going?
I'm strong here.
Do you mean it looks cool that you knew?
Why?
What is gap mo?
Gap mo is when you're designing your voice
and attitudes and...
Are you joking?
Don't...
Give me that.
Right.
We've got two orbitals now.
That didn't do anything.
And there's nothing in the shop.
Right, okay.
There's no point in hanging about
if we didn't get the devil deal.
Right, off we pop.
I want a lollipop.
You're going to gap mo.
I'm going to gap mo all over you.
Petition for saying all the letters in mo.
Moe.
Oh, gap moe.
I want lollipop strong now.
Honestly, that'd be hilarious.
I don't...
I wouldn't mind it.
I think that would be funny.
It's probably being like,
Hi guys, how's it going?
I'm strong here.
Like in my deep voice.
Everyone's like,
You don't sound like you think at all.
Oh, I peed myself.
Thank you, Broly Legend, for the tip.
Um...
I'm sorry.
What?
See, this isn't the thing about Binding of Isaac.
You can play so much
and you end up getting like the most random rooms
you've never seen in your life before.
I can see that tinted rocks.
I'm just gonna...
Oh, and it misses both of them.
You know what I think about you?
You farts, honestly.
Honestly.
We are needing stat up.
We are needing stat-ups, we're needing pills, we're needing anything because this is getting
a bit of a donk y'all aren't you mate?
Okay, we're gonna pop this so we're definitely gonna have high priestess.
There may be sacrifice room on floor, maybe?
Oh, I wasn't paying attention sorry.
Hmm, I've never seen that if only you could throw keys at an enemy.
Hey wait a minute that's an item.
Just out of curiosity is there a girl and veeler that isn't in a pet play?
What?
Wait until you hear the logic behind it.
Remember that time I told you guys that women don't like it if you treat animals cruelly?
Hmm, I wonder why, smile.
Oh for goodness sake!
You're so dramatic, you're so dramatic Keen, get up!
Is that a double tinted rock behind the skull?
Am I going crazy?
No it is a double tinted rock, I knew it!
I knew it was a double tinted rock.
I know we don't have to kill this but out of principle perish.
Again these red fires can only shoot one fire at you, they can't shoot anymore.
So don't get too scared now, don't hurt them now.
Okay so we do have that knife orbital so we can play a bit dangerous.
If we time it correctly we can just jam the knife in the enemies but you know you have to make sure you don't mess it up.
Or else you're just taking XP damage.
Although we do have holy mantle which is negating a heck of a lot of damage.
Yeah again, here we go.
See we just shove our wee orbitals in it and Bob's your auntie, Uncle's your fan or something.
Shit, I feel bad.
Pills!
Why we got speed up?
Look up.
What's that one, hold on, hold on.
Oh sorry I've lost my hang.
Unidentified Pills.
48 hour energy, sure pop it.
We don't actually need to do this room so we'll just teleport to the enemy.
We've got Sister Viss.
Sister Viss.
So we're maybe just do orbital knife on these guys?
Although I would like to maintain my face.
That was so extreme and you know it was extreme.
That was insane.
Oh.
I should maybe just do more.
Right one's down.
Did I just get to stay in astral form?
Why am I so bad?
No!
Right you're getting nuked.
I'm so bad.
Oh we get Bookworm.
Right, ultimate.
Grab this.
So we've got Bookworm but I'm keeping this because it's infinite health.
And we're going to the El Diablo deal and we're just grabbing it.
Thank you El Diablo.
We have our Drosidae Vildil.
Received that.
No, see it doesn't give me infinite health.
God how far in the map did we?
Whoa this is a big map, isn't it?
It's not an XLR4.
The purple, red can keep firing you.
You want it?
You want me, I'll sit here and prove that the red only shoots once.
Sorry that was gamer instinct, I just knew.
I know it doesn't make sense but I just knew, okay.
Oh, that was not the one we wanted but hey ho.
Actually, oh we got Lucky Penny.
We're at 6 luck.
If we could get a trinket that had something like that.
I keep dropping more heart.
Okay, we're literally full on money.
Thank you, a key beggar.
Maybe not right now.
No, rooms like this I wish we had flying.
Holy moly.
The bugs are coming.
We need to be careful of the bugs.
They're gonna steal my little holy mantle.
You wouldn't steal my holy mantle, would you?
A wild card.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Kiff?
Charly?
I think I said that right.
Thank you for the tip, I appreciate it.
You're literally reducing the gen 2 goal.
Not even kidding.
I very much expected a greed fight.
I am not at all surprised.
Whoa, good block.
Good block on the orbital knife.
That was a fantastic block.
No, stop spitting out spiders, I'm getting annoyed.
No, don't give me double spiders please.
Okay, the mulligan fly.
We need to perish because they always hit me when they're on a poopy.
We need to find gen 2 before the donor thun so we can focus on gen 3.
You want me to pop out gen 3?
We haven't even been a 2 months here yet.
We haven't even been a hero.
Whoa!
Okay, my tears are now connected with damage.
Oh my god.
There's no way, hey, hey, hey.
Now there should, there looks like there's going to be a secret room here at the bottom.
What?
Oh come on mate, cheeky.
Okay, there we go, we got both our secrets.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Give me that bad boy, are you joking me?
So we did just take a tier reduction, but the reason why that's so good,
as if that didn't push the thing up there,
we now can block enemy projectiles by firing.
That's right, according to the encyclopedia of,
we are what's called MLG proof.
Nope.
Oh, that didn't get the guy on the bottom.
Ooh.
Hey, I'm going to pop my ult.
I should probably hold it for the next floor.
Hold!
But it's fine.
Yeah, holy crap.
I can't believe we're doing a mega scene.
I'll take that to the next floor.
Unless this card up here is way better.
I don't know.
Still got zero damage.
I knew, I knew, I knew damage.
Weird damage, no damage.
Okay, we'll grab this heart and then we are good to jump off this floor.
Now we have had one greed fight.
I believe the next floor is our last chance for a shock.
So if we get a greedy greed fight,
it's ogre.
I don't know if I should use this key burger.
I'm going to go for it.
Now I might regret it,
but I might not.
Have you ever thought about that?
Okay, I regret it.
We'll go down to what?
I don't know.
Okay.
Brave.
Okay, we'll go down to 10 keys.
Okay, give me that.
10 keys.
And here's a gift for you.
I enjoyed every second of that.
I don't want to go to that chest because I'm too lazy.
Look at all that money.
I know I'm literally max money.
The game is like more.
I'm like, no.
Low shot speed is always nice.
You can still pick up the batteries.
Oops, did I forget the batteries?
Okay, so this is our last chance for a shock.
Is it going to be a greed fight?
Odd say yet.
Our survey says I.
Okay, we can bomb the absolute...
Mmm.
Okay, our devil deal went up, which is good.
Good.
Okay, we have this.
What are we looking at?
See, Holy Mantle is so OP.
I am very happy.
No, don't jump.
I hate him.
He jumps and he's stinky because he lands on your head.
Oh, please.
Okay, that's better.
Okay, I'm just going to pop out so we have all black hearts.
So if we do get heart,
the game says nephronomic effect smile.
All right, I do this.
There's no way.
Either this one's going to go good or not.
Oh, I came to Lake Leech.
I'm sorry.
I think leech is a cute bit to me, but I think we can do better.
All right, we'll grab this.
I like leech.
I do.
Are we going to blue baby?
Up or down?
I think we may have to go down.
No, not unicorn stump.
Thanks for the attempt though.
No, not anti-gravy.
You suck.
No, not scatterbombs.
We should have taken leech.
It's going to blow up on the next one, I think.
Are you...
I should have taken the leech, the cute little wiggly boy.
Sometimes it's all about taking a wiggly boy, OK?
So...
Oh, I lost my heart doing that.
I thought I was being so smart, being like, ha ha ha.
Ugh.
Well, it's fine.
Sometimes good enough is best.
Literally, the game punishes you for thinking,
for having the audacity to try and get better.
Uh...
What?
Is there a room, potentially?
Uh, I don't have an orbital.
OK, the electricity does help with guys like that,
where they can only be hurt from one side.
I do see the tinted rock.
I mean, maybe we'll get a golden chest out of it.
I'd rather we actually get golden chests
and the chance to spawn an item,
or keys, I guess.
Uh, than, like, anything else at the moment.
But yes, we're going to do cane.
And if I have yapped a bit too quickly,
then I think we'll give a Zazzle a cheeky run, as well.
A Zazzle actually starts with flight.
Now, whenever you play this game,
you notice that flight is very valuable,
not only for mobility,
but to get access to items otherwise you wouldn't.
For example, we don't have access to that money.
Now, we're lucky our economy is so high that we don't nest,
so there's a sputter.
Get that sputter!
We don't actually need it.
Is there a tinted rock?
I can spot it in here.
With your bad eyesight.
Oh, gee, son, is that you?
I'm teasing, I'm teasing.
Ooh!
I am so bad at reacting to that.
I just was like, yeah, smile.
No, we could have had a leech on our side.
No.
The game's taunting me.
I could have had a leech friend.
Spitters are quitters.
Flight is for cowards.
No, it's so OP, though.
Okay, what happened?
Is there a rock?
I can't even see.
Oh, there's a gap in the ground.
I can't even see what I'm supposed to be aiming for right now.
Okay, here's the moment.
Oh!
As if it just did that.
Lol.
See, this is why holy mantles clutch.
Last time I was saved by the...
Wow, that's...
If the shops could be any more disappointing,
I don't even think this is possible.
Now, normally I'd be like, yay, vault,
but I actually don't think we want to.
I don't, it's not...
We have such low damage to recharge.
It's like damage per 4 increases,
like, nah, we're literally going to take ourselves away
from even having the...
Did that really get me?
See these wee hings?
I've got nothing but the audacity to tell you that much.
Is there really no sacrifice floor?
And I've popped the book.
I better have popped the book.
Oh!
I need my glegs on.
I'm saying, oh, you've not got your glegs on.
I've not got my glegs on.
Honestly.
As you get for questioning my loyalty,
we got tricked with the backstab.
Honestly.
Not one sacrifice floor.
I'm so sorry to backtrack,
but the value of having a sacrifice room
is like pretty high because we have old bandage,
but we got it once and then the game was like,
nope, that was your one chance to shine.
Never again.
I'm like, okay.
Of course you get me.
Like, you're not even near me.
Right.
We'll see you perish.
I did all that backtracking for a chest.
Enter an unclear boss.
Fully recharges the activity.
Wow.
That was rubbish.
Once again, I'd like to thank Holy Mantle
for carrying us exactly.
Without you, I could bomb that thing back there.
I'll try.
Literally carried by the wafer,
carried by Holy Mantle,
and now getting again with the three and not a card.
Rubbish.
You can take it.
What, the trinket?
Oh, you're right.
This is the last floor.
I could have done anything with this current trinket,
which is pay to win.
Sorry for the backtracking.
Yes.
Mercy has a full video coming out on her channel soon.
For you who use Holy Harvester,
we're so shocked she played it.
Yes, she's getting a highlight reel of it
because she just loved it so much.
But management's going to tweet out
that we need editors for Shorts
and for, oh, why did that glitch out?
I have the mod that lets you see her foot coming down,
but I think it's bugging out right now.
I don't know what blue mum means.
I don't know if it means she's more aggressive.
Oh, I've lost already.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh, no.
This can't be.
I'm going to lose.
We are solo energy.
Sorry, we're having to take the negative
because this is insane.
This is absolutely terrible.
No stat upgrades, actually.
If anything, stat down because lost contact,
but her stat's down.
I don't want to sacrifice too much of my health for this
because the next few floors,
they do have cheeky enemies that take out your health quick
and I really don't want to go low.
But yeah, this is cheekily not the best.
We could definitely be doing better with just about everything.
Leave my dead body alone.
Yeah, this is a unique situation to be in.
Oh god, we've got flight now.
Okay, I can deal with flight.
But yeah, that's how lower damage is.
Just nothing is happening to Mohen.
Oh, well, I'm going to pop my ult.
Maybe the net cross is what's going to take her out.
The net cross effect.
I think it's 60 damage by default.
If you get page two, I think it increases to like 60.
I meant to say 30 if I said 60.
This is not going to go well.
I'm trying.
Come on, game.
You must realize my health is low.
You must know how terribly low my health is.
This is excruciating.
This is a crawl.
I don't know if I need a bomber.
You know that?
Okay.
Pardon me.
I'm sorry.
We did fail the devil deal, which is a shame.
We are going to have to take the damage, the negative.
So we're going to have to drop down below Satan.
Satan.
Bless you.
There's a cough.
Actually, hydration check.
I think I'm about to start coughing.
I love my boomer gamer veto words.
I'm not fucking boomer.
I'm not even.
I'm not even millennial.
Boomer.
I'll shove a boomer up your arse.
Okay.
We don't have anything else we can do on this floor.
We're going to take the Satanic Bible with us.
T-boy is pretty old mummy.
What the sigma?
Let's hope we can get a devil deal as well as a devil item on this floor.
Because that would make the world a difference if we got some of that good stuff.
I'm wondering if brimstone shot.
Oh, you're done.
Brimstone shot would still have the negation.
Like they can't hit us.
What's the fight room?
Tell you what.
Let's just do that.
Zoomer, but somehow also not a weeb.
Well, we're watching anime together.
She better get recommended me the ones I need to see.
I've seen the ones that everyone's seen.
Like attack on titan, death note, kill or kill.
I've seen what needs to be seen.
So you guys can actually start recommending me animes.
And we'll do full binge anime days.
I think runescape.
We might do a binge because I got two more streams and then I've got my 99 on runescape.
So that's another goal met that I wanted.
And then we'll do weeb days.
And then I'll call it the weebification of strawnae.
I'm going to pop this just to make sure I've popped it.
That's a lot of enemies.
I'm trying to get the one in the corner so I can run somewhere if I need to.
But it's not really happening.
The enemies are so polite.
They just don't walk into me.
My favourite kind of enemy.
I'm watching dundum iron-blooded orphans.
It's pretty gay.
Cowboy beatbox.
I've seen samurai shampoo.
Is that really not a hit?
Oh!
Why did I not see the dam?
I did not see it coming at all.
It must be the confidence that you give me reeflings, honestly.
That's right, I'm turning this on you.
It's your problem.
It's my problem.
Please item!
Receive triple shot.
Triple shot?
I mean, I guess.
We can use it if we're in a pinch.
See, flight for a room like this would be so helpful to avoiding attacks.
No confidence.
You give me all confidence.
Oh!
Okay, we can at least go in the curse room to check it out.
Let me get up.
Let him get up.
Oh, one more.
One more.
Some of these enemies do not want to be vanquished.
I'm so used to them coming flying at you.
Okay, we can pop this.
Maybe a guppy item?
Speed?
Sure.
Oh, guppers!
No.
The game really wants me to take it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you can get a library?
What?
I didn't know you could get a library in the room.
Well, we've already got that.
I'll go at ten keys and no more.
I didn't know you could get a library down here.
Oh.
I'll take that.
I don't mind if I do.
A devil beggar.
Sure.
Boom.
Well, you can actually do something with the money.
I had no idea you could get it down here.
Do I have access to a shop?
Sure.
I'll take it.
Thanks.
Did you get 20-20?
Yeah, I got 20-20 bookworm.
Hey, hit him with it.
Gobi.
I love it.
I love the jump animation.
It's so cute.
No, go away.
You stink.
Ow.
Okay.
Did I use the book on this floor?
I have now.
I've used it twice if I forgot the other time.
I don't like these guys.
I wish we got more pills dropped actually.
Now that I think about it, six luck but not getting pills dropped.
Hmm.
Curious game.
The game knew I picked Kane.
Hmm.
And I had Lucky Foot.
This game wants me to suffer.
Admit it.
You want me to be upset.
You want me to vanquish and cry.
So not only do we have contact lines, we actually have PapaFly which protects us from incoming
projectiles.
I get, yeah, literally I can just spray them down.
Feels good, man.
Okay, hold on.
Alright.
Doesn't mean I'm immune though.
Can I blow this up?
Yeah.
Sure.
I'm sure that would come in handy.
So what's down here then?
Just a random room.
Whoa.
Just a room to punish you if you got a bit curious.
That's all.
Oh, we got Back Saber.
Back Saber, proct.
That's right.
The word is proct for you noobs that have never played this game before.
It means the effect came into play.
It's okay if you're a noob though.
I'll look after you.
What the heck?
I rarely go against this boss.
Wow.
They get...
Hold on.
I need to pop this.
I never go against this boss.
I hardly...
What?
It has a phase freaking worm too?
And of course it's not projectile base because that would be too easy.
Right.
Damage up.
Thank goodness.
Are you kidding me?
We got a Krampus fight.
Our damage is now seven so we're actually looking decent.
A Krampus fight.
At least give us Lump of Coal instead of his head.
At least...
I didn't realize he could spin in a wee circle like that.
I said Lump of Coal.
I can't believe that.
I wouldn't have gone any worse if I tried.
Lump of Coal.
And we got head.
Look, head's good for you but for me not really.
That's terrible.
That's awful.
The way it just rolls off my tongue as well.
That's terrible.
Oh, of course there's pinworms as well.
How could we forget?
Okay.
I have no idea.
Oh, then we've got an arcade.
Okay, we can utilize our monies.
Arcades don't need keys.
They need a single cent.
Hmm.
The arcade machine took a full health.
Not a wee one.
I was going to say we can maybe get IV back.
But if it's taken full, I don't think so.
Oh, please.
I think I can just mow them down.
I don't need to aim if it's a projectile.
That's a mimic chest but because we have Holy Manta we can grab it.
Yeah, this is a womb floor.
Ooh.
The classic womb room.
Give me that.
Right, popped all.
So we're 100% getting a devil deal.
Whoa, we beelined.
Oh, I hate this guy.
I hate this guy.
Please.
Please be nice.
Okay.
The enemy, the secret room can't be in that previous room.
Maybe here?
Yeah, okay.
That's the best we can do.
Increase our chances by popping his cloaks.
36%.
It's not the best.
He's alright.
But yeah, that's pretty much all we can do.
Women downwards always is full heart damage, dang.
What am I meant to do beneath our desk now?
You can lick my toes.
That's terrible.
That made no sense if no one was reading chat.
I apologize if that came out of nowhere.
It's because I didn't read the full message.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
Okay, we're going to commit and we're just going to spray down the center.
Because I think we'll, okay, unless she does that, unless she does that attack, then I'm
not sure we can out-shoot this.
Just take your time.
We can out-shoot that.
That's fine.
We have orbitals as well, which are also protecting us.
We have gone full defense this run.
Actually, now that I think about it, this is just full defense.
I need to remember to go down after this fight.
Can you reach over there?
Seriously.
I must remember to go down.
Come on.
Please don't start laser beaming.
That's when I can't keep up.
That's the very move I was actually talking about.
Funny you mentioned that.
That's actually the very one.
Okay, we failed the devil deal, which is a shame.
Let's just go down then, I guess.
Just cast Feet of the Lea.
There's plenty of things to look down there.
How much longer are you going to play for?
More meh.
Oh, wow.
This run's actually taken a lot longer.
I think we're only doing one run today and then I'm going to redirect into Sheepster.
Oh, there's an eyeball.
Okay, we're fine.
I don't know if Sheepster's is up yet.
Okay, we've got bombs.
I'll probably just read a few marshmallows after this.
I didn't realize how much of a yamper I am.
I do apologize again for anyone who...
Oh, I don't have flight.
For some reason I thought I had flight because he had flight.
Although that's not how the game works.
I would love it if I did that.
Pop and all to confirm that we're getting a devil deal item.
Sheepy has a collab so she seems later today.
Sheepy, are you dodging me?
I'm starting to think you're dodging me.
Smile.
Yes, for anyone that is listening in,
I will repeat myself in a few days' time,
so don't worry if you didn't hear it at first.
There's got...
Wait, is the enemy still in this room?
Oh my God, I thought that.
I was like, wait, are you still here?
Hello, is anyone here?
I can't do any membership streams
or ASMR streams for three weeks.
But I will always make it up to you
because you know what I'm like.
So all I can say is thank you for your patience
and waiting on me.
You're joking.
Fricking...
But my gen mates, you can find their links
in the description below.
They will be doing ASMRs,
though Mersi had a fantastic ASMR role play
if you want to check out the VOD where she went to.
That was really good.
I found it really good anyway.
Considering she knew to the ASMR side of things
and producing it side of things.
I mean, we can try and find the secret room,
but yeah.
I think we'll just go for it.
I'm going to pop the hanged man.
I'll see if I regret it, but...
Oh, and Holy Mantle's gone already.
Lovely.
I might just pop the thing so I have the Necro effect.
Please don't spin. I'll cry.
It's not too bad.
It could be worse.
It could be a heck of a lot worse.
I really hope we get a good item
in the treasure box.
Is it the dark room it's called?
Oh wow, the card didn't last.
Okay, we can just keep spraying
because we have the dodge on the things.
As just as he's going to keep spraying.
Do you mind?
Papa Fly is going so ham right now.
Well, that's what we didn't want, but that's what we got.
Okay, we got that. That's fine.
Oh, I just got hurt by something.
Something's... I have no idea.
I don't have a concept of what's happening.
Okay, lovely.
Please don't...
I swear if I die because I'm just trash,
I'm going to cry so much.
I literally have Holy Mantle.
Imagine dying with Holy Mantle.
I'm not even playing the loss.
Okay, don't do that again to me.
I suck and there's no charge things back there,
so I'm just going to...
Mercy went all out in the stream.
It was good. It was really good.
Honestly, you're scary when you say that you will make up
for it last time.
You did four streams back to back.
What will happen?
Please take care.
Oh, you already know what's going to happen.
It's going to be like multiple membership streams,
multiple public streams on the same day.
Or endurance streams back to back.
Nope, don't need money.
Taking damage spawns a permanent demon.
Oh, of course I don't get to see my health either
because that would be too nice.
I'm going to take flies.
I like flies.
I'm just going to grab these. Why not?
We have Holy Mantle.
So we can what? Come in and out.
Holy moly.
I love Holy Mantle.
Enter in a room poisons all enemies.
Yes, that's a good one.
We got egg as well.
So we get soul heart and we can negate 20% damage.
That was a really good room to get all things considered.
I hate these guys.
They're terrible.
He's super scary.
He just got me.
Sorry, hold on.
My fingers falling off the analog stick.
He's so scary.
I hate him.
The wee mask guy.
Come on, blue baby.
Beat him up with your wee flies.
Oh no, you're not blue baby.
Sorry, zombie baby.
Dead baby.
Rotten baby.
I forgot his name.
An egg.
It's literally an egg.
Look at my head.
I'm an egg now.
I literally have an egg head.
Who you calling an egg head?
Look at my head.
It's an egg.
Secret floor.
Secret room, sorry.
And it's not a pill room.
I can't believe I'm actually asking the game to give me a pill room.
That's when you know it's bad.
Relax.
Okay.
Well, I deserve that.
Are you?
I'm actually going to die at the end of this game.
Please.
Okay, that was lucky.
What do you?
Oh no, he has the brimstone aim.
He has brimstone aim.
Like all lock things, my Bobber.
And he's going to do it.
I don't know when he's going to do it.
Okay, he's giving me spiders.
Yeah, he just did it there.
Did you see that purple charge beam?
I was on a you, you, you mop bag, honestly.
I saw that coming.
If we could raise our base damage,
we could raise our base damage.
We could raise our base damage.
We do have 6% luck.
Honestly, we should probably be getting a bit.
Did I?
I just.
Hold on a minute.
Wow.
Who are you calling a pin today?
What did, did you guys know that match is the secret voice actor of Patrick star?
Who are you calling a pin?
Right.
I'm going to pop my alt because I've no got a scooby-doo what my health is,
but he needs when he needs.
Right.
The fear is actually helping to take enemies off of her bat.
Oh, this is a terrible room.
No.
No, that's what I didn't want.
How am I supposed to negate that?
I don't know.
He's curving.
He's not straight.
Why is it curved?
You got me.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm just walloping them.
Okay.
I don't know if this boss fight is going to go well.
I'm going to keep all my bombs for the boss fight because I don't trust this.
He's by the pope.
Donating cause I'm sad.
I can't watch.
Just listen.
You'd only hear me right now.
Are you at work?
Don't make me start.
Thank you, Broly legend for the tip.
Patrick is a neat and still makes ends meet every month.
Wait, you keep people actually say ain't got a scooby-doo.
That wasn't a sigh up.
No, we say that.
I've not got a clue.
I ain't got a scooby-doo because scooby-doo are always looking for a clue.
I've not got a scooby-doo.
What's going on?
I've not got a clue.
It's not a sigh up.
It's real.
I promise you British people are real.
I'm sorry you had to learn this way.
That's a good something.
Oh no.
I may have just killed us.
I may have just killed us run dead in the water.
Oh yeah, piggy bank.
That'll sure help.
Yeah, thanks piggy bank.
Yeah, thanks.
I accidentally picked up a quarter which has no value at all in this run.
When I desperately need health and I keep messing up.
If I could just mow him down before he mows me down.
I can't tell if that...
So sometimes the game puts down bombs to give you a hint that the secret room's there.
But obviously you can't, you always believe it.
Okay, that was lucky that Toxic Shot came in clutch.
So again, we're going to try and mow him down and make him scared because his attack is insane.
I do not like his attack.
Okay, that was lucky.
This is not lucky.
That's not lucky at all.
I really would like...
I would really like a chance to survive, please.
I really don't want to lose right at the end.
I'm going to be so sad.
There was a guy there.
I didn't realize he was there.
Toxic Shock is definitely helping do some damage, which I'm glad because we don't have a lot.
Damage and taking damage, taking damage shoots away to assure.
See, I...
That was four.
I'm kind of stranded because my car broke down and my phone's almost there.
That's like...
Are you called...
Are you called a mechanic or whatever?
Nah, I believe you.
You can win this easily.
Wait, they're real.
I thought it was just a joke.
You only lost one red heart, but I don't have any red hearts now.
Are you scared?
It means I have very low soul hearts.
Because we had four red hearts, so we're now missing four hearts.
And I'm taking damage in every room.
Like a dum-dum.
Okay.
Were we just saved?
Oh.
Turns all troll bombs into safety ones.
Well, I'd rather take the safety ones.
Did we just get saved by Cricket's Head?
I think we did.
I think we just got saved by Cricket's Head.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm gonna pop this instantly.
Okay.
I think we just got saved by Cricket's Head.
Holy moly.
I'm gonna just spam my wee bombs.
Now the purple might wrap around.
Okay, we're gonna spam the bombs.
Whoa.
Okay, see, that's what I didn't like.
I'm just gonna spam bombs.
There's nothing wrong with the bur-bur-bur spamming.
None wrong with spamming the bombs.
Okay, we actually did it.
Sure.
Let's do a victory lap.
The lamb can't kill you with shielded tears, mommy.
I don't believe in myself.
Okay, seller one.
Right, we are just gonna do one run.
Oh my god, we're so strong.
Okay, now we can be picky and choosy.
Continuum, absolutely.
I love continuum.
Very good.
We now actually have range.
Let's go.
Adult and adult?
No.
I don't wanna take these.
Yucky.
Stinky.
Right, so we're doing what's called a victory lap,
which means you basically get to go again
and keep all your items,
which is pretty cool.
So we might get a chance to get-
Oh, we got BFF.
I forgot about that.
Okay, we're gonna go to the room.
And we're gonna grab this.
Spectral tears and flight.
Yep, we're gonna grab it.
So this is where things get super OP
and things get super duper easy.
Which is exactly why I like this.
I'm gonna take BFF.
We'll take Buddy in a box.
Why not?
We'll try and get the conjoined transformation.
If you get Mum's pills, why not?
Range up.
Health up.
Balls of steel,
which gives you two soul hearts and power pill.
But yeah, this is the cool part about Isaac.
It means more time with moment, yeah.
We're gonna do this.
Now, normally you could just obliterate through it.
Sadly.
Wait, what's going on?
Oh, whoops.
He wasn't taking-
He wasn't taking the health I thought he was taking.
You didn't see that, okay?
You didn't see that.
That was rather embarrassing.
I wasn't paying attention, okay?
I wasn't paying attention.
We could grab the heart in here.
Fill damage, yeah.
Whoopsies.
I wasn't paying attention.
Thank goodness we're OP.
Oh, health up.
Oh well.
Maybe we can get a-
Oh, look at that continuum already.
Looking spectacular.
Don't mind the fuzz, please.
Can I get an item?
Come on.
Give it to me, Rachel.
Show it to me, please.
Yeah, this is why I adore-
What was it?
Radiation?
Toxic shock?
It's just so good.
Come on, give us-
No.
Flight for the room.
We've already got flight.
Mommy's throwing!
No, I'm too OP.
I need to level the plane field, okay?
But yeah, look at that.
Oh, so satisfying.
Did you know that if you don't attack,
we fly then it'll buzz away
and you'll get an item on lock?
Leviathan, speed and damage.
Like, this is what we're talking about.
14.37.
Damage.
We'll go next.
I like Super Meat Boy when he's fully transformed.
It's so good.
Do your best, mommy.
I will!
And we're gonna do so MLG in this game.
Okay.
Again, a room with nothing.
Oh wait, we can go in here.
Okay, let's see.
Can we get so hard?
Stompy.
So hard.
Balls of steel.
And we've got El Diablo.
Oh, it's so satisfying
when you do a frickin' victory lap.
I'm so sorry.
If you're ever bored of Isaac,
do a victory lap.
It's just like, oh, that's right.
I'm mowing you all down
and there's nothing you can do about it.
Take it.
Whoa, we got C-section?
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, the babies are cute.
Look at the electricity coming from them.
C-section is like an insane amount of damage.
And they have homing.
That's right.
The babies will home to you.
Nah, you just need a tears up.
Birth rate?
All future floors will contain
an upgraded arcade room.
What?
That's so cool.
What's that?
Full health.
I'm not going to spend my money
because I've been spending another shot.
Oh, toxic shot just took over there.
Right, that was a shot, wasn't it?
Unfortunately, we do have...
Oh, that's a sticky penny.
You can't pick it up.
Unfortunately, we do have the curse...
What curse is it?
The no mapping curse.
But I think I know where I'm going.
I think I trust myself.
Let me grab this.
But look.
Looky, looky.
All done.
Sure, we've got conjoined.
Yay!
Shoot normal tier 7 pair of damage.
I mean...
Did we just take him?
I feel like we replenish our health so quickly.
There's no point in like skipping.
I feel like I'm feeling it.
Okay.
C-Section and Shield of Tears is dumb
because they keep firing homing Shield of Tears.
Never seen that item after 200 hours of this game.
What one?
Oh, your profile picture is my eyeball.
I recognize my own eyeball anywhere.
Don't forget to use your item.
Yes.
I popped that mouth like bang.
I gave it that hook too.
Okay.
Look how big my little guys are.
They're so big.
No.
I'm just...
We could honestly just speed it to the fight again.
I like taking my time, you know?
It's not all about a race.
Sometimes it's about the drone.
And now I'm mad I dropped that trinket
because it didn't occur to me I could do a victory lap.
But it was the best thing to do at the time.
So we just accidentally skipped an entire floor.
Telepills has a chance to take you to the error room.
Which is what I managed to do successfully.
I don't know why that one broke my mantle,
but the other ones didn't.
Oh well.
That's unfortunate.
I did not expect a...
I am error room from that.
Well, we might get a planetarium.
You know what?
We might get a planetarium.
Spawn's a devil beggar, sure.
I don't have health.
You're asking the wrong Isaac player for health right now.
I'm gonna pop my ult.
Now we do have...
We got fun guys.
So I get a size down and I get range and speed up.
So my hitbox is like smaller.
My...
My followers are bigger than me.
My little...
Familiar, it's not follower, sorry.
Are literally bigger than me in the game.
I love being tiny, it's so cute.
The gate.
You have type cent chance to ignore damage.
Oh, I forgot about that too.
Right, so we're supposed to have upgraded arcades now.
Is this the upgraded arcade experience?
Because it doesn't look like it.
I can tell you that much.
Look, shite.
Damn right we are.
I love being tiny, it's another way to say that you like...
Giant?
Why do you think there's a giant here?
Why do you think she can be as tall as a skyscraper, huh?
I made it that way.
Did I use my ult?
I'm just gonna pop it.
I can never remember.
The damage, I know.
And it's only going up every time we get more money.
Money.
Call me Mr. Krabs.
Okay.
Gonna let the game do its thing.
I do have a sock.
Now the explosion can hurt me, but it's a homing explosion though.
How kill was that?
What do you mean it's super dangerous and I shouldn't do it?
What?
Oh come on, we're just having fun.
What do you mean this is so risky and I shouldn't have picked that up?
Oh come on, live a little.
You're such a worrier little weak one.
No way.
Pop ult.
Gumpers?
We got gumpers.
Yup.
And we got gimpers.
We're in a gimp suit.
Any hero members?
We've got a gimp mask.
I'm not even kidding.
It's actually in the game.
Perfection.
That's a big boy.
Gen 1, the crater is barely disguised.
Pink.
Honestly.
It was so fun.
Now I'll also say Gen 2 is not being created in my image with my particular interest in mind.
However, depending on a few things, it's very unique what we're appealing to.
What's the rib of greed?
5% more coins and fewer hearts from room clear.
Greed and super greed no longer appear.
I mean, sure.
Whoa, what did I just...
Experimental.
Shot speed up.
Let's go.
Not good.
I like it.
Considering how your luck was at the start, this is quite a turnaround.
And whose image is it created?
The janitor?
No, the concept.
I submit what I want.
I'll show you how it works behind the scenes.
But I submit what I want and either I get it or not.
And I just send an art focus board.
Again, with the second concept artist, I sent her a board of stuff I was interested in.
She sent me back her version of that.
Does that make sense?
That makes sense.
That's English.
That's how it's been done.
But again, I'll show you all the behind the scenes.
Obviously, Gen 1 was a bit chaotic because it was my first time ever doing anything like that.
So, it was rather...
It was a stressful time.
Let's put it that way.
But the reason why I'm so happy to talk about...
And uncomfortable to talk about Generation 2 is because...
It takes a year for...
God, balls of steel again.
Again, it gives us two soul hearts, which is just fantastic.
God, birthrate on Cana's Bazaar.
I don't have time for these machines.
They're going to take too long.
You know those flames can spawn hearts?
I didn't... when bombed?
No.
What's in here?
La bomba.
Now, if I could get blue fly from the shop, that would be great.
Hive mind, not blue fly, sorry.
Hive mind.
No.
But nice try.
Made in mommy's image.
Gotta love the wounds.
I'm not reading that one out, but you're welcome.
It's literally like top tier.
Sorry, I don't care what anyone says.
That's weird.
Good thing it's fantasy then.
Smile.
Upon death, we spawn Isaac in the same room with half a heart.
Speed and massive size then.
Wait, so I can be a tiny baby?
Wait, you didn't know about the blue flies giving blue hearts when blown up?
They are very much like a ball.
You didn't?
Wait, what?
You didn't know about the blue...
Oh, the blue fire is giving soul hearts.
Yes, no, I knew about that.
She says that she walks right into it.
No, I did know about that.
Why not?
We might as well do this.
I'll blitz this over you.
Yeah, good luck surviving this.
Yeah, that's right.
Now we do the boss fight.
Unless we want to do the angel.
I can be your angel or your devil.
I can't see shit.
Yeah, it does happen.
Let's not waste too much time.
I don't want to waste your time.
I want it to be entertaining.
I want it to be peak.
I want it to be high.
Conga time.
Like, game Isaac be like,
we go up this time?
Yes, we can go up.
Hey, we can get shooting orbital.
Oh, that's so good.
Oh, thank you, game.
No, really, you shouldn't have.
You should not have.
Just keep that.
Strongly move ball.
Cathedral music is my fave in the game.
I really like,
is it Ghana?
No, wait, that's the country.
Hold on.
The mausoleums?
It's not Ghana.
I'm sure that's the country.
Yeah, Ghana is the country.
Gehena.
Gehena?
That sounds exactly.
Powerpill.
No, thank you.
Gehena.
Any Gehena
rappers?
I don't know if I should do that.
No, go all out on El Diablo.
Is it country?
You're probably talking about...
Yes, okay, outside.
Oh, wait, we're already on the last floor?
No, our last shop.
Cannot be.
Don't say such things to me.
I'm enjoying this run.
But yeah, if you play victory lap,
you can pretty much ignore everything.
If you won once, you can, you know, do it again type thing.
Wow.
Oh, wait, it's not open.
Open.
I just let the flies deal with them.
Please open.
Thank you.
Another victory lap.
No.
Okay, we'll take Poki Gold.
If clearing a room would yield the reward,
it gives you coins.
Sure.
Okay, maybe one more victory lap.
Just a little one.
No.
I don't want one makes you larger.
You suck.
I'm back to being normal size.
Okay, maybe...
We know where the secret rooms are,
because we just picked up Tuesia map.
Wow.
What's in here?
A bomb.
Okay, so that was a waste.
We're not getting many bomb drops.
That's my only ditches of my complaint.
Oh my God, you're complaining about the game
that you're smurfing right now?
Yeah.
What?
See, if we had Keeper's sack,
I would have picked this up possibly,
but I do like that we have infinite health.
I'm not sure.
Any bombs?
Pills.
Two soul hearts.
Adult.
50% to try and die.
The die appears only then the die doesn't pick up.
Balls.
One makes you larger.
Do we want that?
I don't think so.
I've not used it, so I don't think I want it.
Because that's how it works, right?
If you've never used it before you.
I think there might be a secret room.
There's not.
I was going to say,
how have I not consumed all the pills yet?
I feel like...
I've seen them all at this point.
Day's fast proof.
Mummy, can you check for marked rocks at all?
I'm full health.
Is that naughty of me to ignore them?
Oh, we got boss rush.
Sure.
Do you want me to go up, right?
You wanted me to go up.
Let's go get this.
And then we'll do boss rush.
Yeah, that's perfect for what we need.
No effect from BFF.
Stinky.
And then boss rush is in here.
Ready?
Right, we can take...
Taking damage reduces.
So that's kind of like the way for it.
Isaac's movement.
Charges forward.
Dies in one hit.
Oh, that's terrible.
Um...
I guess this is technically the way for after one hit.
Abel, my brother that I perished.
We'll do the sea bomb.
They're already perishing.
I can't remember how many rounds there are,
but I think there's like eleven or something.
But we'll...
We're just gonna send it.
To no one's surprise,
we're just gonna spam upwards.
Boss rush?
More like massacre, exactly.
Um, if you are trying to get unlocks,
unfortunately victory lap,
like this doesn't count for unlocks.
So don't...
Don't think you've got a way out.
I thought I was so smart doing this.
I was like,
I will get all my unlocks to be a victory lap,
because how can anyone naturally get boss rush?
Uh, no.
I...
My first boss rush was on Eve.
I accidentally got it on her without realising.
I was like,
Oh, what's this room?
Uh, and...
Yeah, basically stress myself out to high heaven.
Who...
Who or where is this enemy?
Ah, there we go.
At least give them a chance, you bully.
No, I need my full health.
Give full health or perish.
Could you imagine you end up doing enough victory laps
to the point the game crashes?
Well, funny you mentioned that.
If you do enough victory laps,
the game actually starts removing your items.
And then you become the lost.
It's really bizarre.
It just happens.
I do not want chocolate overridden by C-section.
Damage scales with the charge time.
Wait.
It's overridden by C-section.
Yeah, so I keep C-section.
No, I don't want to add to the charge time.
What did I just pick?
Did I pick something up there?
Health up.
Sure.
One singular health up.
Chucky milk.
Name a more iconic duo then.
Oh, hey, what's this?
An incoherent stream and I'll scream and I'll wait.
You're always stressing.
I mean, one of them is bar.
It's not really useful.
Yeah.
I think we'll pass on Chucky milk because that...
I don't know.
It says chargeable tears.
Damage scales with charge time.
Wait, no.
If it comp...
Does it complement?
Maybe it complements?
I have no idea.
It didn't really state it changed anything.
Sure.
Let's go.
I don't know if I made it worse or better.
Somebody come get her.
She didn't just like us.
We go arcade with this.
And of course, I can't see my health.
Because why would I be able to?
I'm going to pulp this to make sure that we get our Chucky item.
No, we need more damage.
I do need more damage.
I can hear my data weak.
He's making a call for me.
Make me a T-ball yet out of me.
Okay.
We might be able to get an item out of this.
Nope, that was wishful thinking.
We do love a bit of wishful thinking around these parts, don't we?
Yes.
So actually, this is a little thing.
So you see how we can see top right the other secret room?
Because it's a super secret room.
That's an indicator.
It's actually where the boss fight is.
I did consider it.
It's very plausible.
I think my landlord is nice enough to let me install a temporary pool.
I mean, I put a damage up a bit.
Give us film towel kits.
Oh yeah, we should be picking up money because we have...
That pool.
Your dad would make you tea.
Yeah.
It's kind of custom.
You know, you make your family member a cup of tea.
Like when you go, do you want a cup of tea?
You offer it to each other?
Who or where?
Whoa!
Oops.
Oh, we get mother transformation as well.
Yes, mother.
Oh, random rune shard.
We're going to step over art tile.
Maybe we'll get...
No, that didn't work.
Well, we tried our best.
I can't always work out.
Whoa!
17.68.
This is getting astronomical.
Two soul hearts.
I'll hold on to you.
I'm going to hold on to that.
100%.
Thank you for the tip, really legend.
I definitely considered for 3D.
I'm not going to pretend otherwise.
Definitely considered.
More damage because reasons.
Why, yeah.
A library again?
Oh, wow.
You can pop this one because it gives us a wee familiar.
Oh, I've got a wee fly that goes around me.
Save first.
Imagine.
Interesting.
Here I come.
It's common that the younger one serves the older one.
Not in my household.
We're just kind of like mom's pearl.
No, that's definitely not my household.
Everyone's just nice to each other's smile.
It doesn't matter when you were born.
Because that's like cheesy doodling.
I was born for...
It's giving I was born first.
That's what children argue on the playground.
I was born first.
You have to be nice to me and do as I say.
No, that's not how it works.
Not from around these parts.
Not from around here.
Age has no correlation to how nice you can be.
I mean, we don't need it.
But we're going to take up the money.
Because it's not about the money, money, money.
I don't see the appeal of pole dancing.
You don't?
Isn't it like normal dancing?
No, it's like supposed to be all...
Have you never been to the Unicorn Palace in GTA?
You've never been to the Unicorn Palace in GTA?
In no way.
3D Ring Fit Adventure Stream.
I do have a Ring Fit coming out next week.
Next week.
But yeah, if I get 3D, I'd 100% be down.
I'll pop my ult, but I don't think I need it.
Sure, let's go in the secret room.
So again, we can see where the other secret room is.
And it's an indicator that most likely...
Who or what did that?
Oh, not up to it right now.
I'm going to pop this guy so we can get increased.
Yeah, there we go.
A 1 tooth piece.
Imagine...
Oh, we get damage up for it.
Let's go.
19 damage.
Hair tier.
And that doesn't even include all of the other effects that come with it.
I'm surprised we're actually getting room cleared.
Wait, the boss room isn't this way?
I can't believe that I've been lied to.
Reduces all Devil deals to a heart.
It doesn't reduce the other ones though.
No, I've actually...
My item I've got right now...
I use Black Feather.
Every evil item I own, my damage goes up by 0.5.
And because we're taking tons of Devil deals, it's going up.
I'll pop my ult.
Okay, well, I shouldn't have.
But I did.
Whoa, we get fire rate up and 3 coins.
I think he just passed the boss room.
I saw a health bar on the screen for a moment.
No, that can't...
It doesn't work like that, you goober.
You're teasing me.
That's not how it works.
Oh wait, why does it go that way?
Okay, let's...
Oh, we're at 20 per tier now.
Oh, will we do Hush?
Let's do Hush.
Oh, it's Dark Bomb.
Okay, you come in and then...
Killing an enemy has a chance to spawn the ghost.
Here, you come in too.
And then we'll go do Hush.
So Hush is the last time Isaac breathes.
Hush can't fight back because of the shielded tears.
Hey, Stony, can you kill the boss again?
I blinked.
Yeah, I can kill that boss again.
Oh, that was a good kill.
Oh, I had balls of steel on me.
Oh, the music's on.
It's the music's on.
We've already got last...
Wait, how did it double up?
Would it have just become bigger?
No, I wouldn't.
So normally there is a crawl space in these rooms.
I do say the term normally in quotation marks.
Okay, I do say the word normally there's a hidden...
Oh, grants immunity to explosions and damage.
Okay, normally there's a hidden crawl space.
Normally...
Yes!
There we go.
Normally there's a hidden crawl space.
And we got Hush.
Okay.
I love how Stony plays the same game over and over.
She just let me through for real though.
Bandit only took me like...
Chose between two items?
No, that's terrible.
I think I'm better just keeping my minions.
I'll pick up a tally pill.
Right, we are ready to take on old Hush.
If you look at the wall decorations, you can see the faces of the enemy.
Roll a d4 for the memes.
Are you kidding?
I've never had such a good run.
That's kind of funny though.
Maybe we go to Delirium.
What we do, Delirium?
We could.
Where is we?
Get over here.
A monkey on a pool.
Well, you need to give me time to learn.
Thank you for the tip, Iron Reaper.
You need to give me time to learn.
But, I mean, a bit of cheeky 3D tracking on.
Get me going.
We roll your whole bill, should we?
Right, how about we go take on Delirium.
And I'll re-roll my whole bill.
I'm gonna not go well at all.
I'm not even paying attention.
I'm just spamming.
I don't even know if I've lost any health.
Look at the purgatory just going crazy.
See all those little red guys?
Oh, is that why I'm getting fed pills by a dark bum?
Alright, we'll re-roll into Delirium and see what happens.
I'm gonna regret it so much, but why not?
Whoa, he's crying.
Don't cry.
Or should?
Maybe I shouldn't re-roll.
I'm scared.
Do we have to re-roll?
Okay, I don't want to do Delirium.
If we do Delirium, am I allowed to not re-roll?
Because I quite like what I've got.
I've got like Guppy, I've got Mum, I've got Flay,
I've got Spectre, I've got everything.
Don't re-roll, don't re-roll.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Right, well, do Delirium is...
Thank you.
I am doing a victory lap.
That is why I have so many items on my Persons.
That little flag means I am on a run.
I'm on a rune.
Speed up.
I'm already...
My speed drives the telepills.
Oh wait, you can't get a...
I was gonna say you can't get an I am error with this kind of stuff.
Alright, what's in here?
We've got the Headless Horseman.
She's on a victory lap.
Don't risk it yet.
Well, do Delirium.
Health?
Don't really need health.
Sure, we can open that.
Again, with Memic Chest, we can just straight up open them
because we have Holy Mantles, so it's not a problem for us.
We are gonna get the Secret Room that's over here.
What's inside?
Absolutely nothing.
We've been trolled by the one...
Oh, well we'll take the money because again, we have deeper pockets.
We actually should be picking up every single penny, but I'm being lazy.
Something's happening over there.
Debizzle can pick up all these.
What just happened?
Oh, nothing's getting me.
What did you just throw at me?
I don't know what he gave me, but thank you for it anyway.
I'm quite happy with that.
Health turns off Polaroid.
Yeah, I'm not gonna pick up any red.
Again, we are gonna try and pick up as much coin.
Got Toxic Shock because I've got so much damage.
Toxic Shock is actually killing enemies as we enter the room.
I mean, I'll take a quarter.
You don't have to tell me twice.
We just went up like a full mom's heart.
Oh, tears. Absolutely.
We can fly over everything.
Now, Delirium can only spawn...
Strony Dominating is just natural.
So you admit it.
I'm a dumb. Got you.
And 4 Key.
You admit it yourself.
Thank you.
There is a tentacle here.
Maybe an item.
We got money. We got money.
We don't need that debuzzle, but thank you.
I've been in that room, so we'll go this way next.
We'll pick up.
No, you big sub. How dare you?
You just admitted I wasn't.
We get a stat up from this pill, whatever it's gonna be.
Luck.
I think we've got enough luck for one day.
I'm gonna be honest, little guy.
Dumb only in this game.
Mummy gets moonies.
We're fully, we're fully all in on black hearts, actually,
which makes us super potent.
And we got page 2, which means we do extra damage.
Now, I'm curious if delirium, because we know where the other secret room is.
If delirium is next to that secret room.
Adverture.
If that is an indication.
We're at 23 damage.
Can we get 24?
Right, I'm gonna go up on purpose to try and collect as much money as possible.
And get as much boss fights for extra items as possible.
Cheeky item? No.
24 now, between every shot.
That's amazing.
There's so much going on the screen, though.
Time to mega-mush in a rock bottom.
I don't have rock bottom unlocked, I don't think.
I think you need to do boss rush Jacob and Isle on hard mode.
I don't even think I have rock bottom.
I wish I could get rock bottom.
I'm so curious to unlock death certificate, but I'm so far away, so...
I really suck on Bethany.
I have a really hard time on that.
Where am I going?
Anonymous, thank you for the tip.
I'm curious, do you spend time playing with someone special?
Or would you say you're competitive gaming to win?
I...
I guess?
Because I like playing with you guys, I'd rather have quality time playing multiplayer games.
If I'm not good at a game, I don't play it.
That sounds like such a sore loser, but I am.
If I'm not good at the game, I'm just like, what's the point?
I suck.
I don't want to put my time into something I suck.
But Elden Ring, for example.
I'm absolutely terrible at Elden Ring.
I have never had so much fun playing a game.
Commentate and stuff in my face.
You guys make that game so fun for me, and you make it playable for me.
Because if I had to play it the natural way, like the actual way...
I don't think I could enjoy it, so it's thanks to you guys,
I can literally enjoy a game that unironically wouldn't be accessible to me
due to my stubbornness of, oh, if I'm not good at the game, I'm not playing it.
Because I don't spend overwork myself,
and then go, oh, you know what?
I fancy getting absolutely demolished in a game for eight hours.
I don't really tickle my fancy.
It might for some people, but for me, yeah, not really.
That is a friendly enemy before you panic.
Please don't panic, guys.
We've got two balls of steel pills, so I'm going to keep them on hold.
We've already got max speed, so...
Do you have any tainted unlocks?
I do, I will show you after we finish this victory.
It's a turd, it's a brownie.
That's kind of the point of Souls game.
Well, I mean, I can enjoy it with you guys, so I don't count.
Really, alabaster box?
Right, you should be ashamed of yourself.
More like, full of rubbish box.
Thank you, I'll be here all week.
Right, I'm purposely avoiding that last boss room,
but I think that's where our enemy resides.
By the Pope.
I'd basically come to you and be like,
Riefling, I can't get past this part,
and then you have to come through and get me past it.
And then 20 minutes later, Riefling, I can't do it.
Thanks for the tip, Anonymous.
Literally, you're trying to do your own gaming session.
I'm like, Riefling, please, I can't do this.
Right, it looks like...
We're here.
What the f...
What?
Emmanuel Coppa?
Coppa D's nuts and my mouth.
Thank you for the 50.
Gluck Gluck.
Are you serious?
That's a lot.
Thank you, Emmanuel.
Jeez, Louise.
Wow.
Thank you very much.
So we're like a big brother to you,
then playing the hard parts for you.
I mean, literally.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Congrats to everyone who caught that with their faces.
You might have a prompt in chat.
That'll tell you, like, oh, I think Delirium's in that room, by the way.
You might have a prompt in chat where you have to, like,
enable the thingy-ma-bobber.
You just do that, and you'll hopefully catch it.
I do have new emotes coming very soon to you.
Very, very soon to you.
The girls are getting their emotes first,
because, you know, we can be patient.
But thank you so much, Emmanuel Coppa.
That's crazy.
I'm still assigning people to even get the gifted membership.
And thank you, Broly Legend.
Not gonna lie, I would love that.
Yeah, you'd love carrying me in my games.
Mummy's sitting on her lap as we help her.
Emote teaser.
Blast from the past.
Are you squidding me right now?
Stroney's the little sister that gets you to do the hard parts of the game,
and in return, she does the hard parts for you.
Ay, yeah.
What's that mean?
I don't think I know what I mean.
Ah, shot and behavior.
Holy crap.
Literally, it's still going, Emmanuel.
It's still going, right?
Hydration check.
That last part isn't for you.
Oh, of you, and does the hard parts of you.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
What a spammer.
I can't believe it.
No, I'm kidding.
Do not time anyone.
Jesus, are you joking?
Congrats on the membership.
Yeah, congrats on who caught it with her faces.
Oh, crap.
Thank you again, Emmanuel.
It's 50.
50.
That's a big number.
Okay, sometimes there's wee numbers,
and sometimes there's big numbers, okay?
That was a lot of money.
How much money was that?
Is that like $300?
Oh, God, that's insane.
Thank you, all by Isaac.
Small loan of a million dollars?
Exactly.
Yeah, okay.
Delirium was next to the secret room,
which is very curious.
Now, thankfully we do have lost contact,
but Delirium...
Now, Edmick Muffin...
Who goes there?
I mean, that sounds like a deal to me.
Thank you, tiny spiny.
Oh, I just lost my holy mantle.
Oh, no, I lost holy mantle and my blanket.
I actually had two because I'm just so good at the game.
Hold on.
I'm MLG pro-gaming.
I'm not owl.
I'm not even looking at the screen.
I'm cheating.
Wah!
It's ogre.
We're dead.
We did it!
We did Delirium.
Wee!
Oh, Parisic.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Oh, I like that.
Hold on.
No, I like that because I can information dump on Isaac
and be like,
Thank you so much for getting me rock bottom.
I need to return the favor now.
Isaac, my boy.
There he is.
We scale it in.
Look at his repel this.
His wee hip bones are jutting out.
Thank you, Anonymous, for the suggestion.
Thank you.
That is my concept now.
I now own the legal rights to that idea,
and no one else is allowed to do it.
Copyright holder, scrawny culls.
More like rockin' your bottom.
So that's dad walkin' away on the hill, rip dad.
He's walking away forever.
That was it.
That's the binding of Isaac repentance team.
Poor Isaacers, honestly.
Get her rock bottom so she can go down to your rock.
How long still until scrawny plays Roblox?
I've never played Roblox.
Now, I will say one thing.
I saw the funniest TikTok,
and it was like Roblox jumping course,
but you only jump by your mic getting activated,
and I was like,
could you imagine the noises all six of us would make on Roblox?
Being like,
whoa, whoa, like trying to get the mic to activate.
It would be absolutely a zoomer,
but she's never played Roblox.
Right, I'm gonna say something controversial,
but does Roblox no give you absolute five-year-old vibes?
I've seen people roleplay as a cashier
in a hairdresser in Roblox,
and I'm like,
I think this game's from the younger,
young, young, youngins, you know?
The ending song hunts my nerves.
Jesus loves you.
That's good, but the louder you scream, the higher you jump.
Roblox is like a kiddie game, I swear.
Yeah, it's like younger, zoomer.
Bro, it looks like it's for five-year-olds
that if they would get their first game,
I feel like that stream would get demonetized.
But anyway, this is my save file,
so for my tainted characters,
I've got tainted Isaac, Madeline, Cain,
but as you can see,
I have hardly achieved much and tainted.
Oh, it almost gets me like,
that's where Dad's singing to us.
But I've done Greed Mode.
I really like Greed Ear and Greed Mode.
I know a lot of people hate it, I don't mind it,
but there are quite a few that I haven't done.
Like, I've not unlocked Tainted Eden.
Lost, yeah, surprise, surprise,
I haven't got much about that.
What about the death penalty?
Lilith, Keeper, Polly on,
The Forgotten, Bethany,
Jacob is locked, I've not unlocked him,
but yeah, my tainted isn't very good.
Greed Mode, hey, taking Lilith to Greed Mode.
I don't know, what's for your tainted version?
Betrayal, Fetal Fury, and Jello.
Jello's pretty strong.
Jello's a strong ba-ba.
Jello has ult lock as well, if I'm not mistaken.
What, do you want to try a Greed on Lilith?
We can try it.
I don't expect to win, but we'll try it.
I always feel like clearing my safe and starting all over again
when I watch streams of this game.
Are you a god?
Oh wait, no!
I thought it was going to be Jello as an active item.
Oh no.
We are not making it out with this one, Chief.
Look how slow I am, I'm so sluggish.
Yeah, we're not making it alive.
Oh, we have lucky, oh wait, you don't get pills,
you need bi-pills in this game.
Ooh, it's not happening.
Thank you Anonymous for the tip again if I didn't say thank you,
because all I said was stealing your idea.
You have Honing and a Whip that does three times damage.
I mean, if it has Honing, there's a chance.
If it has Honing, come on Jello, if we can get BFF
in Treasure Box, I assume.
Oh my god, look at the...
Go Jello!
Keep me safe down here.
Wow, there's jobbies.
But I do not suspect I will win,
but that's not going to stop us, is it?
Come on Jello.
With that aimbot, come on Jello with that aimbot.
Hit him with it.
Don't shoot, just whip.
Oh no.
Wait, are you sure?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're so right.
Wait, what hit me?
I don't know what hit me.
Something got me, I don't know what it was,
but I guess I deserved it.
Oh my gosh.
Hit him with it, whip.
Now watch me whip.
Now watch me, that must have been made so many times
considering how old this game is.
Yeah, dang.
I'm so slow though.
0.85 movement speed.
I'm late, but I still made it.
You're lucky I was fatigued enough to
commit to this game mode.
I thought I was going to have my
freaking treasure box
thinking my bobber, but I don't.
I've forgotten what Feetal Fury was
or what my passenger was.
Is that the tummy thing?
I am whipping the crap out of this thing.
Wah.
Whoa.
Juke.
Juke, go away, Juke.
Go away.
You have respect, my Paratain.
Oh my god, I feel like Cartman
because I'm so slow.
Okay, one more fight.
We're going to ignore the devil
deals.
We're going to go angel deals.
Oh wait, can Lilith only get a...
Oh, well that was very unfortunate.
Did not mean to lose that.
Ooh.
No, I can get angel deals.
Okay, that's fine.
We are a puppeteer now.
I wonder how many even got that
song reference.
I feel like that was popular now.
Watch me whip.
Watch me now.
Right.
These are all pish.
That can get people.
I'm probably going to regret this,
but I'm going to sacrifice...
That's why I regret it,
because you need to go in with sugar
and spice and everything nice.
Right, we'll take our monies.
Oh, I thought Jill could pick up a heart.
But we cannot.
Okay, let's go next.
Let's go next.
Let's not hang around.
Let's not beat around the bush.
Any beat-bushers?
Any bush beaters?
Sorry, I said it wrong.
That song was in almost every vine
bought back in the world store.
Right, we've got tier rate up,
so does that mean the whip is faster?
He's so fast.
He's such a baby.
Oh, we've got Haun.
I like Haun,
because he goes and does damage on his own.
Anything that goes away
and does damage on its own,
I'm like, are you?
Yeah, Jello's giving us the range
to not be attacked.
Right, pick up the key first
and then grab Haun,
because I think Haun's a cutie pie.
I like Haun,
because he goes and attacks
all the enemies for me.
Are you?
Wait, how does that work with Jello?
Oh, he spits out.
He spits out C-section.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so lucky.
Oh.
I'm here for it.
My yum heart.
Yum yum.
I like that.
Thank you, Anonymous,
for the suggestion and the tip.
I need to write all these down.
I need to get, like, a document,
because you guys give me
such good suggestions.
And I like making content
that you want to hear
versus what I think you want to hear.
Like, I'd rather...
Oh, my God, Haun is getting it.
Go, Haun, go.
I'd rather, like,
feel more confident writing stuff
that you guys, like, want
than me guessing that you want.
I don't know how I didn't get hit there.
I got...
Right, we kind of need a bomb.
Well, that's a bomb, all right.
That gives us health and a bomb.
Hmm.
I think that's...
Right, I know this seems crazy
because it doesn't do anything.
The odds of rolling a bomb
are terrible.
At least we have unlimited bomb.
Ooh!
That goes pepper's goods.
Nerd Girlfriend talks
about Isaac Lowell doing it
the entire time.
Well, I really, like,
I'm surprisingly enjoying it.
I don't know if you guys
like that.
I'm surprisingly enjoyed
writing Ignore.
I'm so surprised I liked it
because...
But it does, like, have funny things
where I could, like, be playing a game
in theory.
Oh, no, that was terrible.
Right, I'm not popping this anymore.
In theory, it could, like,
lead Rise to me having to carry on
with things like that.
Because it is just, like,
a bit of goofing off.
And I can be, like,
Girlfriend's addicted to
Binding of Isaac while she ignores
but gives you free use
ASMR, like, that kind of stuff.
Oh, I'm too slow!
How did I dodge that?
I have no idea how I dodged that.
That is hilarious.
That was...
I have no idea how that just occurred.
I know I should be whipping,
but I'm terrible, okay?
We're gonna blow up an angel.
That sounds terrible.
Okay, and then next...
Okay.
Oh, and we got a frickin'
and it's fearin' him!
Come on!
This is so good.
And we can sacrifice health
to get a bomb if we need a type thing.
Very nice.
Let me read the
suggestion again.
Ooh, baby.
Man, I've been an MVP, literally.
Casually just
Morgan everything.
Right.
I
can now go into the
curse rooms without any issues.
Some issues with the curse rooms.
I'm so slow!
Please, no more bombs.
No, I'm so slow!
That's what I didn't want.
And it happened anyway
because I'm too frickin' slow.
Now...
That's really good.
I'm gonna take it.
I know I probably shouldn't,
but that's really good.
Now, I can blow up
like that.
Yeah.
Okay, that's good.
I'll take the penny.
In for a penny,
in for a pound.
Your mama.
We are gonna blow him up as well.
As I said, now that we can
kind of sacrifice Red Heart
for that.
Strony a snail.
Honestly, snail confirmed for Jinto
because that was
absolute slow poke territory.
That was awful.
I mean...
We could maybe do one attempt
at the secret room.
Okay, that was lucky
because, yeah,
I only had one chance.
Can you hypnotize me
to finally stop procrastinating?
That one's out of my
experience level, chief.
I'm afraid you're on your own
for that one.
I don't...
It's happening again!
Oh, my lord.
It's happening again.
Okay.
We now have a panic button.
We have a panic button.
I repeat, we have a panic button.
We're going to go as far as we can.
But...
Yeah.
We've got Curse of Darkness,
which is a shame.
Um...
But we've...
Okay, okay, hold on.
Let him get up.
Can you grab that for me?
Jello, bring it...
Jello, bring it over.
Right.
I am going to get that key.
I'm just going to go and
explode for it.
Um...
Well, we can maybe get a chance
to get the secret room,
which is exactly what I was hoping there.
Huh?
Two back-to-back...
No, that can't be...
My code is QQ3G80R2.
We can't have both.
No, we can't.
I'm keeping the R key.
Um...
Where are you?
Large orbital, the block shot.
It splits into smaller versions.
The smaller version breaking
into blocks.
I'm just going to go and
explode for it.
It splits into smaller versions.
The smaller version breaking
into blue spiders.
Respawn.
Okay, so kind of just
spider, spider.
Rider, rider.
We're going to...
We're going to go for it.
We do have a...
We can bomb the angel.
If we get an angel,
then we can get 100% angel deals.
So we don't have to sacrifice
any health for any of those
good things.
Oh, I'm too slow for this.
I am too slow for this.
We do have a chance
for blue smoke as well,
which is good.
I'm going to pick up our weak lines.
Streamer luck.
Actual streamer luck though.
I was like,
oh, I don't know if I can win this one.
Well, you know,
my confidence has gone up a little bit.
I'm not sure why.
Totally not because I've got an R key,
but streamer luck don't mean
if I do.
Okay, steady.
I really do not want to lose
my holy mantle.
Although we could just leave
the room and go again,
can't we?
Yeah,
actually,
I'm over-complicating things.
Classic women women.
Ah,
where is he?
I'm just going to let them
kind of deal with them.
Are you squidding me right now?
By the pope.
I just wanted everyone
to have a chance to
have a chance to have a chance
to have a chance
to have a chance to have a chance
We have a pirate. They're so fast. Oh my god. I shouldn't have done that. Why did I do that?
They're so fast. I've just cornered myself.
I need to do this. Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh. I don't know how I got away with that.
This is a scheduled and pre-recorded tip.
No, it's not. Stop it. People are gonna believe you.
Thank you Spidey for the tip. Never punish. She hates us. I don't hate you. What the heck?
I haven't said anything. Right. We've got the key. So now we have 100% angel chances, which is huge.
We got very lucky there. That could have gone really bad.
Rather fortunate. You see? Oh, we've got actual bombs this time, so we don't need to keep hurting
ourselves. Right. No point in deep poke. Wait, hold on. If I'm resetting, is there odds of me getting
like a rune like Yara or something? Huh. Self-proclaimed Dom keeps foregoing and uses the whip, honestly.
Right. Because we're gonna reset, this might be worthwhile to pick up. So I'm gonna do it
against my better judgement. Taking damage has a 50% chance to spawn something. Not necessary,
so I'm gonna just destroy this. Did you pick up that coin, but you didn't pick up the key?
I don't know. Nothing's really speaking out to me. I'm gonna just walk away and go next,
because I'm not really, not really sure, am I? One good shop is all you need to do the infinite dopes.
She loves this lovely replay.
Right, we did get the angel deal. Short speed, I'll take it. What's the card? Pickups? They're
turned into horror. Okay. Here for another NSFW concept. How about a solo audio for Patreon?
Stromi reads some of the thirsty marshmallows from Reflings and becomes overwhelmed with lust.
She can't help but to inquire reading the Maros. So Patreon don't allow live recordings,
but Twitter does.
I'm very much thinking of doing a menu, which I think you guys will approve of.
Oh wait, I'm a dumb dumb. I have fire. I can destroy these guys for free if one of them procs a fire.
Come on fire, fire, fire. Give us fire. That's just what Twitter will do when she got shy, honestly.
Twitter for the dub, yes. Don't be surprised if you see a lot of Twitter content over in August,
I will start taking it super duper serious. Wait, okay, wow. I forgot you could do that.
Right, speed. Now, normally I wouldn't waste my breath on speed, but in this occasion,
thank you for the tip again. Hey, Stronny, it's me. Type view and aim here. Just here to watch
my favorite Scottish streamer play. Insert whatever game Stronny's playing today. Good luck and enjoy
the stream. Love the content. Delete remainder of message. This is DonoScript number 39.
You know what's even worse? You trolling about with this, you creasing in your little chair. I'm
about to release a short that's like, this is how much I earn to obviously like show that like
the other, you know, something to worry about us. AI generated viewer response. Stop. And everyone's
going to be like, oh, it's an industry plan. She's like faking the numbers or whatever. No one's going
to believe me. No one's going to believe the numbers when I show them. If our 49201, thank you
for becoming a member and all the numbers out there in your name. But thanks for becoming a member.
Insert positive message here. I believe you. Stronny, you're going to have to punish chat.
Oh, well, you're getting punished because you didn't get nothing for three weeks.
How's that for punishment? Oh, dear you. Are you squiddin' me right now?
I've got to go, mum. My phone is at 5%. I'm going to miss you.
Okay. Thank you for hanging Broly legend. Rip your phone, Barry. 5%. You win as a fellow acoustic.
I believe you. I can keep for three weeks. Okay. This is the cruelest punishment imaginable.
Thank you. I can't believe I have to thank you. Thank you. Type Donator name here.
You're done. Right. I'm going to get the speed so we can actually, you know, not get wrecked and
decked. Oh, I do love a bit of Damage.
I'm going to grab a key. We are going to pick up that damage because that is well worth it.
What are you? Taking damage can make invincible. Oh, and we can huff pills if we happen to unlock
any. Good luck. Yeah, hope your cargo will not explode. Smile. We have been infiltrated
by the High Table. We need a purged room of A. Thank you. You could get a Rune Bag at some point.
That is what I'm hoping for because we're going to have a reset. I'm like, hmm.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Back it up, man. Even the pot of speed, I'm still slow.
I am good. That damage up is certainly going to help with our little C section, but
these guys do not care. Oh, I hate everything about those guys. Come on, buddy. Okay, thank you.
Oh, not you. Come on, haunt. Come on. I really need BFF. BFF would be so beneficial right now.
I'm going to grab these right now.
Oh, there's a ghost. I actually got him somehow. And I dodged the attack of that guy somehow.
Well, the pregnancy is more to be followed up with C set. No.
That artwork should actually be coming through soon. So that's going to be hilarious to write for.
Actually, oh, dad, I'm going to wait and record. You need to be quiet. Oh, what are you recording?
Pregnancy smart.
He's going to be like, what the fuck are the reflins in there?
He's going to wonder if these are all okay. Okay, we're going to leave the room to get Holy
Man all activated back again because we did on four. Shouldn't we just lose it there? Why are you so tiny?
Oh, I'm just spraying my little C sections because they will attach to anything they
do get hold of. So it's not like bad. Oh, there's explosions. I'm getting them reddish boys ain't
right, but perfect. Like my mom and dad knew I was a weird kid. So I'm sure they're not even
surprised about any of the shenanigans I get into these days. There's like, yeah, yeah, that's
strong. All right.
Right, we're going to leave. I'm going to pick up damage.
Health, but short speed down, but tears up.
No, we deserve better than that refling. Your C section with them having C section on their own
is horror material and play some weird stuff going on. Funny, you seem there's normal kids out there.
Oh, I have 71% chance with Anna.
There's a difference. Oh, that's hilarious. I'm telling them you said that.
We did not get your daughter pregnant. So that's amazing.
Sorry, I'm trying not to lose any health. I really don't want to lose fully mental. I think we can
get another angel deal. Praying it's a good one. Come on, give us
what is it? Or give us full. Whoa. I don't, I think haunt.
71% angel deal, by the way. 71% angel deal. You forgot the yet we didn't get your daughter pregnant
yet. Reflings, you can't say that about the convention. We're getting trouble if you skip.
I'm skipping. Give me these coins. Give me these coins.
Right, I'm going to blow up the machine because there's nothing I want in this
lot. So just blow up. Whoa. Hold on. I'll take Seraphim.
Yes. Yes, I will. Look at that. Whoa.
Wait, no one say anything about the convention.
Okay, I can't grab these coins. No, no, they have to leave.
Yeah, it's a shame that D6 is getting ignored, but it is what it is.
A little flower, a little flowery.
What are we looking at? Range, luck and a soul heart. I will absolutely take it. Are you joking?
And we could just got five cents from that fire. Not bad at all.
Are we skinny enough? Are you serious? Okay.
I need fire to burn these guys. Come on. Come on fire. Oh, and I missed. Okay. Well, I'll try.
Come on fire. Isaac got pranked. It hurts even though Archie has more value. Yes.
The reason
the stream is longer than I thought it would be. Yes, I am slightly addicted to Isaac.
My pro dad's been up for a while. I'm just getting ignored right now.
Today we're going to Bunnings, which is the equivalent of being cute. We need to hire a car.
Go do a car rental because I don't drive. I ride a bike.
Oh, come on. Bunnings is B and Q in Australia. And I'm picking up sand so my cats can shit in
a sandbox. This is true. Oh wait, we have neutral pills. Health up and another health up. I don't
know if I want too many red hearts though. Right, what are you? Sure.
The stage transition nightmare shows the wrong items in greed mode. That's hilarious.
Range and tier size. If the C-section babies are big. That's a good thing, right?
No, so thankfully Bunnings isn't too far away, but that taxi driver was,
he was on it. He must have been on the sniff or something because that was erratic driving.
That was horrible. Although I will say one thing about me. It was nice enough to stop on
the side of the road. Like we were on the fucking highway and I was like blabbering about like,
oh, I'm going to get my dad's of the airport and all that. And I was like, I'm so sorry.
I need to be sick. Can we please stop? And he stopped on the highway and you're not supposed to do that.
How would it be a traditional Scottish ride and all the reef links and kick kills?
Yes, that's when you wear kills that way. The booger sugar, that's such a good way to call it.
Tier size. I think we'll do tier size up. Why not? I don't really want anything else.
We will pick up the- Are you squidding me right now?
No wonder those cheeks be clapping like crazy. You'll be working them thighs every day on the
bike. Yeah, I ride a bike. I love my bike. I think riding bikes are cool. I may not be killed for you.
Wait, what did you say at the end? I never heard it. What did he say? What did you say?
I can't read it because I'm freaking in mid-match. I don't want to get whipped,
but I'm pretty sure that I couldn't hear the end of it because I'm freaking trying to game.
Okay, we're definitely leaving to get Holy Mantle back. I've messed up this one so badly.
Hold on. You get a spank in a minute.
Oh, jeez, Louise. Come on, haunt. Take them on, haunt. Replay the voiceler. No wonder those
cheeks be sitting on my face and letting me beat you. Wow, refling, that was so direct. I thought
you were supposed to be shy. I'm supposed to be my shy little boys, but you're not. You're feeling
it today. Oh my god. Techpoint 5? Scottish culture. Doms, fanboys. Why are there so many people
trying to make me wear a skirt? No, we don't. It's traditional. I guess meme done so much like,
oh, it's got people wearing skirt. All right, what are you going to do? Shoot yourself? Sheesh.
Oh, more damage. Yeah, we'll take it. More damage. All the damage. Right, we've got Holy Mantle back.
Oh my god. Wait, so the tears are coming from my tummy, but the shots are coming from the end
of Jell-O. That is very curious. Come on, haunt, and Jell-O.
Ow, my mantle. You suck. Give me it back. Thank you for the tip, anonymous. If I didn't say thank
you, I'm so sorry. I'm getting distracted. I, for one, accept my kill future. Strani, please
make an emote for a reflim wearing a kill. I will. Is that what you want? Because I think I have a
few more spots left. Haunt, just having them in the corner. Oh, I'm going to hurt myself by accident.
Are you serious right now?
Converse all heart containers into black hearts. Oh, sure.
Is that, then?
Getting trolled. Pretty fly. For a white guy. Yeah. If we're doing a reset,
might as well not. Well, I'll grab this pill, then. Change my mind. I want it.
Hill. Up. Getting trolled by this game.
Someone else that says damage. I think it's a gamer term. No, is it not?
Oh, I see it. A tinted rock.
Yay. I'll pop this.
Uh, right. We've got the high priestess card.
Wearing a kill means fresh air down there. No smoke path. Yeah, you're not supposed to wear underwear
with a kill. Okay, we'll play this one and then we hit reset after it. Or do we actually do the
boss fight and then hit reset? I feel like we still could have got, whoa, guppers.
Well, not quite guppers, but you know what I mean. It's collar.
Oh, you can just skip this floor? I'm not sure about that. Oh, no, there's no re-roll. I hate
when they have no re-roll. Well, we're going to blow this up anyway, so we might as well take
over to the guys and save ourselves some time trying to get that thing to pop its clogs.
Two out of three for guppers though. Bunk. Oh, under.
D20 can re-roll the... No, I don't want to. Maybe you can find two here. Well, I was just going to
reset. I don't want to buy anything on this floor, so maybe we just play it and then reset.
I was hoping to be a bit stronger in all honesty at this point, but we're not really...
Oh, no, I have Hungie. I'm a Hungie boy.
I will... Tonight, I'm having Steak, and my dad's cooking it, and he's cooking it well done,
and I will not have any slander against well-done Steaks. It's okay to be wrong sometimes,
Reeflings. It's okay to be wrong. Oh, we can actually proc all those guys for coin drops.
Purly. Thank you for becoming a member. I hope you're not Purly though. I hope you are in good
health and have long prosperity. Live long and prosper, smile. Whoa, wait, what was that? There's
something in front of me. I never even saw him. Okay, let's... Yeah, let's burn...
Yes, one more, and then we'll go out and get Holy Mantle. Come on, you want to give me the flame?
There we go. Okay, spider's lovely. Bright woman needs immediate... medium steak correction. Also,
respect for being a cyclist. I'm too scared to learn how to drive a car because I have terrible
perception, and really, I am pretty certain that I would cause a collision of some kind. I don't
know what kind. Most likely, a roundabout. Like, if I was gonna go, but the person in front of me
didn't go, I'd just, like, rear-end them a roundabout. I don't... I do not trust my perception, so...
Yeah, my next is riding a bike, but I've always rode a bike. I love my bike, and it's fun, and I
enjoy it, and I know it's kind of... I don't know, not nerdy, but, like, I know everyone kind of drives.
Okay, we're gonna take the devil's deal, and then we're gonna reset the question mark. Maybe,
I don't know. Or maybe do the fight that's below. There is a fight that's below.
Taking 15 spawns a permanent demon after 30... what? Caps up four familiars total. Should
grab it, and then, sure, just grab that. While we're at it, might as well just take everything.
All right, we do have 45 coins. Can I... please? Thank you. Thank you! Money, money, money.
I never drive. I'm too fear of it, honestly. I know, like, it's kind of one of those things where
it's like, you know what your limits are? It means, like, yeah, I do not have the perception to be able
to drive. I wonder if self-driving cars would change anything. I think you still need to be
able to actually drive, but, like, the license... go license for that. Also, thank you, Anonymous,
for asking to be my bike seat, if I didn't say thank you. In case I was too distracted.
Okay. We might be able to just straight up... oh. Okay. Thank goodness we didn't do that. We almost
skipped steam sail. All right, come on. Come on, flames, you can do it. I wish I didn't have to
drive. Cycling's so fun, because you get to appreciate the nature and so... reset now or do the fight.
Because I can always reset after the fight. Right, if I'm getting hammered in the fight,
I'll just reset if I'm getting hammered. I'll reset. I definitely could have more damage.
About 10% of the way.
I mean, because the C-section is locking.
Okay. Okay. Oh, there's a penny. You ain't mine now. I mean, 60% maybe?
Okay. What are we doing? Health? Right. I'm not giving too much health back.
All right. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Okay, 50%. We will reset. There is another round after this.
All right. I think we can get... Come on, haunt. You're doing it all, buddy.
We didn't get BFF, but we might be able to roll for it. I don't know why the flames are going in
such random direction. Gento. Okay, we did it. I'm feeling confident now. I think we did it.
I was worried we didn't actually roll. We've got it. We got it.
It's okay to be nervous and sometimes self-doubt is natural, but we got it. Oh,
God, please just perish him before all these guys come out. Okay, thank you. Okay, no flame.
No, I'm keeping my money because we're going again.
If you guys have rule plays, let me make sure to send them in Marshmallow. Yeah, yeah,
don't... Yeah, you can do it for free. Stop giving me money. What the heck?
Do it for free in Marshmallow and you can rewrite what you've already submitted. Please don't
think you're ever bothering me by like... All right, reset. Ta-da! We're all the way back here.
Yeah, please don't think you're ever annoying me in Marshmallow or anything. Don't be silly, Billy.
I'm just glad that we can talk on Marshmallow again. Nun's Habit.
Behind the key is the key and a coin. Sure, I'll take it. All right, we're gonna...
Well, there's a meme audio idea test, a self-car. Oh, right, okay.
Right. Oh, we stalk up on Hells. I think that's... We'll stalk up on Hells.
And then we'll... Oh, wait, we'll take Nun's Habit in case of something good.
Fire rate, I'll take it. Shot speed, I'll take it. Range, I'll take it.
Tears and shot speed, I'll take it. Speed? I'm actually a bit of a speedy Gonzalez.
I'll take the Trinket because we actually don't have one.
You're done. Okay.
We'll reroll.
We have two, two diamonds.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. I understand what needs to be done.
I understand what needs to be done. You need not give me... It's not that, but...
Okay, I'm pretty sure I heard him or I heard a bird on the roof. It's one of the others.
Okay, I understand what I need to do and I do have the strength to do it. Thank goodness.
Or just you spin me right round, baby, right round. When you go down, when you go down.
Where's the enemy? No idea. This floor, you cook. Yes.
So we can pop one of the cards and then take the one to the next floor and...
Okay, one more.
Now we're going to avoid the El Diablo. I'm no interested. You cannot tempt me this time around.
I was desperate because... Right, so we do have to pop one card on this floor because we don't have
room for a second card, which is understandable, haven't I say? We are going to... Oh, I should have
done it on the other side, but you know what? You live in your life. So we do have to pop one,
but we can pick up the other one and then use it on the next floor. No, please don't touch that.
Thank you. Okay, and just to make sure I wasn't going crazy, doubles Isaac's number of coins.
Right, once and then we pick this up, we take it to the next floor and then we'll
double what we have on the next floor. Okay, and then we jump down.
Karaoke stream when? After three weeks, if you want karaoke, I can do a karaoke.
Okay, five bombs, sure, and I don't actually want any red health. Goodbye. Oh wait, have immaculate
conception. Oh my god, these are good. Right, don't get distracted. Let's maximise our monies
by getting these guys, sorry, my stomach just made a noise. Karaoke club. I don't think my
ping is good enough for the, right, and then fire. Come on. Fire.
Come on. Karaoke would be fun. Yes, we can definitely do karaoke. I have no problems with that.
Oh, why bombs?
This game's so, oh, I lost my holy mantle. How? I haven't even saw the dying thing.
Right, we're going to back out and go in again.
Even though I should actually try and take damage because we have immaculate conception, but
at the end of the day, at the end of the day.
Okay, okay, sorry, I'm trying not to lose anything right now. Karaoke, you have to stream, my beloved.
Okay, sure. So if I bomb him, do I get anything? I don't think so.
Hold on, I'm so sorry. My dad's literally right outside the door. Even when it's like...
I had to tell myself, fuck off. He's on the phone with my mom and I'm like, stop saying names.
Stop saying names. Pleading with him. Right, okay, what was I doing?
Ah, okay. Sorry, I couldn't hear my ingame audio there.
What have I done? What? What did I do to the game?
Why aren't bombs popping?
Oh, I was like, did I break the game? Sorry about that. I was so confused.
Okay, yeah, so if I destroy an angel now, nothing happens.
I thought I broke the game. I was like, excuse me. Now, I know there is a heart in there, but I'm not
really... I was kind of hoping for a... Oh, I can take pills. I can see forever. I'm
drowning. Is it in here? No, it's not. It's actually down below.
A womb room. If I had a donation machine, a blood donation, that probably...
Oh, I'm just going to pop it now. All right, two diamonds pop.
Yeah, something tells me we're not going to struggle in the...
Sorry, I keep forgetting. That's a delay. I'll just take it.
Right, fully recharges activated. Give me. Give me. Give me. Give me.
Give me. What's my birth rate? Familiar is that normally,
fallotain to the lilas, follow her jello instead. The melee attack gains three damage.
I'll take it. I'll take it. Don't mind if I do.
Okay, we can always see the secret room. Sure. Mother transformation.
It's not really going to do much for me, but it's only seven. BFF!
BFF! My beloved. Okay, I'm going to restock like this.
Oh wait, let's see what trinket we get. 100% wider tears and restock back. Why not?
Right, trap door can give us a new item potentially. Whipping me. Range, heart, no.
I'm going to take this. Oh, there's chaos. Do we rip on chaos? Take the range.
Wow. Do we rip on chaos? Well, we can't grab that almond milk.
It's damage with C-section, is it? Oh, because of the whipping.
Oh, we got a paternal heart for it. I'll stop at you.
I'm starting to think you guys are in a fendom at this rate.
Thank you. I can't believe I have to say this. Thank you. Viewbot number 5109172 for the donation.
You're ridiculous. Thank you. Okay, wow. Jello's so big. Oh my god, look how wide they look like.
Right, well, we do chaos. As if yes or she wasn't any indication. Right, we've done chaos.
Number of bombs, sure.
Two of clubs. The two of clubs. Shot speed, no. Let's refresh.
Bouncy tears, absolutely. Where are you? Cage leaps on an enemy that deals the first
damage to Isaac, deals 90 damage and releases four rock, chases enemies for 13 contact damage, sure.
Spider baby, sure. I'll take it.
Flight, sure. I'll take it. I'm spending all that money. Petrifying tears, sure. I'll take it.
You don't have to tell me twice.
Angry fly for Beelzebub, sure. I'll take it.
A shield, sure. I'll take it.
Bloody guts, sure. I'll take it.
Gumpers, my beloved. I know I don't need it, but I'll take it.
Okay, sure. We'll take it. Oh no, we can't afford jiddy. My shadow, not jiddy.
Wait a minute, Jello can move this out the way. Come on, Jello.
Move out of the way for me. Yeah, I'm so smart. Oh my gosh.
I'm so smart. Why am I so smart? Oh my, whoa. Oh, I thought that was an enemy coming at me.
It's my own thing. Okay, let's do this.
Take almond milk. Can I reach it? I don't think I can take the thing.
Yeah, you need that thing, that puppet thing to get access to this one. It's a troll. We are being
filled. We are being made of full of ourselves. You need the jump book. You're flying. Wait,
what do you mean I'm flying? Yeah, I can't get in.
That's what Reefling said, I can't get in. Just use the back door. Right, if we do this,
it turns everything in here into a bomb. Something exploded over there.
Uh, don't need that. Don't need the bomb. So we'll just nuke this.
Get some pennies back, and then dead eye. Why not? Why not? I will take dead eye.
Okay, let's go. I'll just make sure I picked up everything.
Well, Maze will take that now. It doesn't really make much of a difference. Let's go.
No, you can only get it with the jump book pretty funny.
No, you can get it with that Muppet thingy, you know. I'm going crazy. Can't get in,
because I'm too big. Real entrance.
Hello? Are we about to go crazy? Right, I'm going to purposely get
energy on my dick, so I can dig your hole. All right, money for money. Oh wait, I have flight,
idiot. I'm going to pick up that box, because that's like the most OP thing I could possibly do at
this. Look at all the babies. I can't see anything. Uh, right, we're going to purposefully get...
Ah, sure, I'll take that. You're already crazy. This is overkill. I'm going to imagine if my game
got corrupted, because, uh, not corrupted. Bruh! Bruh, it's so bright in here. Hold on,
let me put reactive mode on, just so you know how is it going to go on. Is that reactive mode?
Yeah, that's how red is.
I have no idea what that did. Well, I'm going to do my wee staircase, and then I'm going to go down here.
Did I really help them with the visuals? Pretty, like, oh, we've got black mark!
Oh, I don't know if it's the one that doesn't let you progress. Like, some of them don't let
you go backwards, so hold on. Hold on, I am going to take this. I don't want to miss it.
Wouldn't miss it for the world, wefin. And then, we're just doing this. Oh, we've got perfection
unlocked! Oh, we can pick it up, actually, because we've got, um, I can't see shit.
Stop giving me devil deals, or you will pay for your crimes.
Roon shard! Oh, I've opened up a wimmy. Okay, we can't do anything, but we are going to go down
to the secret lair. Hopefully, we do get a Yara. No, not, oh wait, no, there is something here.
I hate the game going up where OP is. Um, it's going real good.
We're actually going to take this to add to our damage.
The black rune will consume it, so boom. And we got nothing we wanted. That's okay!
Right, I'm not health, fiery, range. There's no downside to you, I will take you.
Okay, let's go. What runes do you have unlocked? Not many. Yara was actually, oh, it's an error
room. Well, thank goodness I didn't go ahead. It's in here. Oh, there's a chest on him. Okay,
I'll blow him up. Picking up a coin has 21st chance to spawn a red heart. Well, I don't need
it, sweetie. And here you thought you weren't going to finish the run. Literally, I thought I
wasn't going to win, but we winning. We win, aim. Is she becoming on in 30 minutes? Or did I make?
Are you serious? I love chaos. I love chaos. I love chaos. 40 minutes until the collab. Okay,
I will redirect into sheepsters because I always seem to miss her, so I
I literally chaos deniers and shambles. And I get the Seraphim unlock. I know I already have
flight at the moment, but you know, Seraphim is nice. 23 damage. Oh, and a boss room little
cheeky man. Oh, look how big the babies are. They're humongous. They're a baby. Oh, wait,
I'm dumb dumb. Here. No, no, no, no. I don't want to skip. Okay, let's go. Whoa. What are you?
No, not Levitical. Levitical sucks. Okay, I see sack. Guppy's head. Wait,
I already have guppy? Oh yeah, I do because look how much buzzing around. Right, spawns a sack.
Every six rooms. That sounds good to me. Beelzebub transformation.
Not bad. Okay, let's blame him. I missed those things. Okay, hold on to her money.
We might get Yiera, which is in the room. Wait, if I pop my ult, I've popped it twice.
Oh my god, this is insane.
Bro, they can't even spawn in.
I can't even see. I don't. I don't want to pick up the coins in case I've got a Yiera.
I don't seem to have a Yiera. I don't seem to have half rooms at the moment.
Bro, I love this game. See, this is when the game's satisfying and you don't want to like
nuke it into the stratosphere is when you're like winning really easily. I said what I said.
Empty vessel. When Isaac has no red hearts, you get flight and you actually get a proc.
Aw, that's a shame that I've got so much. So, does you drop a pedestal item now because I have
chaos? No, you don't. Curious.
How did that black room get taken out of my hand?
Look how fast I have to charge it again. Barely took two seconds, honestly.
Right. No, I didn't drop a Yiera, but I'll do this one off.
I don't know what it does. Sometimes it doesn't even say out loud what it's doing and I'm like,
um, okay, that didn't help me at all. I am so small I can hardly pick up the coins properly.
Right. Uh, because nothing in here. Was there anything worth?
Every time we purchase something, we might get 0.5 damage.
Chaos deniers in shambles. Shambles.
Oh, and we've got money back, bro. Money back guarantee.
Oh, we can actually get rid of Levitical. We've got range for that, I'll take it.
Cause it's a chance to shoot. Yeah, we're gonna grab it and we're gonna be even more OP.
This is getting, this is getting a bit silly in that. Oh my god, hungry soul. I'll take Bob. No.
Well, we can actually get Bob Transformation if we want to.
Blood Poppy chases enemies. No, he's cute, but he's dangerous. He'll attack you if you're not careful.
It doesn't mean it. He just gets a little excited. Taking damage shoots, uh, sure.
So if we do end up taking damage, they're getting annihilated on site. They don't even have a choice
in the matter. Uh, Papa Fly. Chance Lock, yeah.
For, for $7 we can get 25 coins, sorry, 7 cent we can get. What's this?
I agreed. Every 20 seconds, Isaac shoots a coin tier that deals...
Oh no, I cost a coin to shoot. No, thank you.
What a deal. Literally, what a nice shop. I like the economy in Isaac's world.
You can break it so easily. A Rift? I actually think Rifts will be more dangerous because of our C-section.
Uh, we've got Book of Sin. Spawn's Barriers, no. We might try and go for Bookworm just because we can.
We don't need bombs. We don't need lunch. We can do it again. Maybe we'll bomb it just to re-roll it for free.
Polyphemus? Oh, I'm gonna cream. Oh, and we've got that as well. I'm creaming.
That's a shame we couldn't get that, but I'd rather take the thingy. Polyphemus. You just need Keeper's
head. 76 damage. Look at them all coming out. Brav. This is getting outrageous. This run. This is
outrageous. Oh no, the cloud. It said AFU to us. What, stinky cloud? 76 damage. Feels good, man.
That's a wee rune. I need to find out. Okay, I didn't do anything. Sure, let's bomb this.
What did you drop? More bombs. Okay. Sorry for the brightness. I'm trying to burn the Keeper's over
here. Man, I can't see. I need to leave. Sorry. I literally cannot see. What's going on? Right.
You. I've been needing you because... Oh no, I need... Oh, well, sure.
It's fine. You're allowed to do that. I can't see a thing, honestly. The flashbang in.
It's pretty severe after I've met, even by my standards. I'm like, sirion.
We got baby spin for all our familiars. They're actually gonna have accuracy, you know?
Oh, what are you giving us? Pills?
Wheel of Fortune? Yeah.
Is that what I just did? Is that a passive?
Luck up, sure. Hyrofan, sure.
Pretty fly. High Priestess. Okay, that was a lot. We're not doing that one. That one's rubbish.
Hopefully we'll get a Yara. What now, though? Bingeater. Oh, I like poison tears. I think poison
tears is the way to do it. Oh my god. I know I'm full, but... No, we don't actually need that.
I don't even know why I'm, like, trying to stretch your size with game. I mean, look,
we're not even a cheat. Like, this game's gonna break.
I can't even see. Oh, there's a Yara. I repeat, there is a Yara.
Is there another Yara? Imagine if we drop two Yaras. No, no, no, no, no. I don't want the coins
coming over to me. Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope. Nope. Okay, we've got Yara. Let's pop it.
Was there a second Yara? Nah. Draft. Okay, but we got the coins. That's the main thing.
We got our second Yara.
Okay, you know what? We'll just go for the devil. There's so much health in this.
Oh, I forgot we were not doing...
I'll take it for the bookworm transformation, but I'm not gonna leave with it.
What does it do? It gives a soul heart. Not sure. Give me up then. Pop it.
Oh, thank you.
I could have saved it for the next floor.
What'd you mean, the night?
Saved what, Monkos?
What did I misunderstand? I misunderstood. It does not compute. I suck.
Right, we'll do poison tier. I'm actually not that fussed for...
What's it called?
Benjyter, just because it cycles through everything and I'm really dumb.
Using a rune has a tip to spawn a copy. Oh, that's worth it. That's so worth it.
Okay, the 50% wider is worth it as well. I know I'm down to three luck, but we're doing so much
damage. I'm not fussed for Benjyter. I know it's good, but...
Do you need to save at this point? Probably not.
Tears up. Oh no, tears are capped, aren't they?
Thothic! Thothic. I got Thothic about damage and health. Conjoined, why not?
Enemies explode into tears. Isaac's tears are connected with a beam of electricity.
It's a good day to be an Isaac player. It's a fantastic day to be an Isaac player.
Damage, just whole straight up damage.
Oh, it's a good day. Right, we're gonna bomb you too.
Thank you. What does the cookie do again?
Each of Isaac's tears have a different stars effect.
We're gonna get the Christmas box in here. Oh, wait.
I've got lump of coal, I'm guessing. It doesn't work.
We'll grab it, honestly. We'll just spend everything. Spend them all.
We're melting the PC today. If us, where if this game breaks right at the end?
I'll be region. We're literally one away from the boss fight.
Play the cookie, it's fun. Yes. One here.
Sure, give me an internal heart. Okay, bomb, so it's fine.
What are we looking at? Oh, well, we can actually get a devil horseman.
Oh, no, the fire thing isn't broken. Hold on.
Okay, I think it's propped. Is there one over here? I have no idea. Hold on.
Oh, that's a... We'll grab the seven seals, why not?
I don't think we actually have to play anymore, if I'm being honest.
I think we got Yara instantly.
I got a green shark.
I can't see. There is a Yara. I'm gonna pick it up.
So it's already in my persons.
Okay, okay. One more time.
I didn't even... I didn't even need to do a new shoot.
Yeah, I'm gonna pop the Yara, so it'll be a surprise if there's a Yara up there or not.
Well, that's so good. Thank you for that. Please don't waste my time ever again.
What enemies literally cannot see them?
Okay, we got him.
Good thing. Maybe.
What did that do?
Yeah, it does not do anything. Rune shard.
Okay, let's just grab all this money, spend it, and you.
Because this was like the best run I could have ever asked for.
Literally a reset key. Special shout out to reset key. You did it.
I'm gonna try and... actually, you know what? I have 30 bombs. I think I'll be okay.
I'll just spawn them. Spawns a random coin.
Imagine if we got Lilith giving birth to babies, literally.
She's raising the population by herself.
A whip. No, I want this one.
Could you imagine if that Yara duplicated though?
Could you imagine if it did though?
The high priestess. I got a drowsy repeatedly. Oh, thanks, I guess. Drowsy.
Okay, let's see what we can buy. Oh, no point in the coin thing.
We've got a quick worm. Not bad.
Could just go with familiars, to be honest, because we're about to double the familiars.
Levity in front of Isaac deals... what, ill damage?
Jeez, sure. Give me that. I don't recognize it.
Spectral tears. I think my tears already capped long ago.
Picking up 15 hearts, yeah. Go for it.
We'll reroll a little cheeky reroll. Actually, we're just gonna bomb for it,
because we've not got that much money. Three hell.
Sure, why not? Just give us everything, okay?
Whoa, what do you get? A chest gives you one coin.
It's a bit late for that, I think. We could maybe bomb these.
Okay, uh, I'm gonna bomb too.
Okay. Well, something tells me we're ready for this greed fight.
You know, I'm not too sure we've got it in the bag, but why not? Let's see, one coin.
Okay.
Oh, that was a tough one. That was scary. Not gonna lie, I was on the edge of my seat.
Okay, let's at least get some money to donate to them. Okay, here it goes.
Oh, for goodness sake.
Could you imagine this is greedier of always?
Sure, I will put money in the greed mission.
I'm ridiculous. Let's pop these. Maybe we can get a few coins to put in the machine.
That was crazy.
Oh, we got a few more coins to put in. That wasn't bad.
That was so close. I know we almost didn't make it.
But yeah, that's Lilith on greed mode. As you can see, she's OPE, the Binding of Bosses easy game.
It just depends. Sometimes you can get the best run and it makes you addicted to the game,
and sometimes you can get work, but like terrible run after terrible run,
and it makes you so upset you literally are like, had enough.
So if I minutes until the collab. Okay, I will do marshmallows,
and I will make sure I'm redirecting into Sheepster's. She is broken in general.
Try her if you want an easy run. Does donate and even do anything after the first time?
No, it doesn't, but I just do it because, because why not?
But yeah, that's my save file on Isaac. So this game becomes multiplayer in November,
which is when you guys are going to come in, because yeah, I haven't gotten all the unlocks.
Um, I still don't even comprehend how some of the characters work, like, um.
Who's that? Bethany? I always struggle to understand what she's doing.
Shawnee's going to carry us in this game. I know for once I get to carry you, maybe, I'm not sure.
I'm not, I guess I could start playing. No, it's very, if it's not the game for you,
do not force it. I am so serious when I say that. Bethany is really strong in the city.
I just want the game to play with you. Oh no! You need to make sure you actually like the game.
It's not an easy game. So that, those symbols on the left side are like the unlocks of certain bosses
that have killed, and like, I'm missing a lot. Like, the tattered page means I've done delirium
and all of that, and most of these are like super lucky runs. I don't really get good.
There needs to be a mod where the familiars are replaced by rooflings. I would be so down.
I finished Tainted Lost, then we've go, brev, brev. I've not even started on Tainted Lost.
I'm too, like, this is how the average Tainted Lost run goes. Are you ready?
So we, we have a holy card. We can pop it, so we're now one shot death.
Like, this is, we're not going to make it. Yeah, we've got a sacrifice room that we can't
do anything, and before it finishes the run, no chance. I have attempted so many times and I just get,
like, literally we're down, we don't have another holy mantle.
Or, I've already messed up. Okay, we're not fighting those spiders. Like, this is how bad it is.
Tainted, Tainted is just, like, such a un,
unfun experience. Now, I'm sure it's fun when you actually, oh,
okay, well, right, let's try again. Let me just try and explain again how bad this is.
Okay, we're going to pop the holy card, and then we're going to, you know, just flutter about,
get a few things going on. And we're just going to check out the shop, okay. Mm-hmm, close enough.
Yeah, like, eternal hearts mean nothing, so, yeah. Strony is locking it. No, it's not happening.
I basically, in order to even get anywhere, I would need to roll,
maybe a spoon bender. I'd need to roll that first.
Now, the only thing is, we do have spectral tears, which means we can shoot through rocks,
like that, which is obviously a bit much, much, mutual helpful.
But no, I have never successfully done this. I remember when we both came out and people had
to date, I mean, how to get the lost, honestly. Some of the requirements in this game are like,
right there. But yeah, I basically would need, like, the most OP items ever. Now,
the tainted lost apparently comes with better items. Do we believe that? Let's find out what this
better item is, hmm? Oh, what? Hold on. Hold on. The one item I need. The one item I need. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. The one item I need in order to do this
game mode. The one item I need in order to do this game mode is the sign. It's the sign. It's
the sign. It's the sign. It's the sign. Right, don't mess up. Don't mess up. Don't mess up. Don't mess
up. I don't want to mess up, but those strays from the flies are very dangerous, as well as his
triple shot. Hmm, not a fan. Oh my god, we have an orbital. We're so safe. Let's go.
Focus. This run is real. Better items means you can't find useless items and gives health and
weight. Okay, now I can take a devil deal. That's not a problem. So I actually misplayed there. I
could have killed all these guys without them getting close to me like this. But we can hover on
the rocks safely and I'm taking it. I don't care. You should boost the fight, strongy. No, I don't
care. I'm literally tainted gloss. Leave me alone. I'm just going to blow it up because it's a health
hazard, okay? Okay, this room's a bit of a hazard. I'm pretty sure they have spectral shots. Do they
not? Well, they can come on the rocks. So, not the best room, but we're alive. Oh, we need a key.
Okay, a key. Our coins. Coins are a key. No one destroyed, strongy. I also can't find defense,
like most orbitals, cuba, meat, bandage, or exception. Yeah, nod leaf is taken out of the item
pool. If I had nod leaf, the only reason I've done stuff on the other tainted, the lost in general,
but nod leaf is taken out of the item pool for tainted. And I'm like, ah, great. The only thing
that is keeping me alive during all my runs. Nod leaf is the MVP for me personally. Okay, I have a
key. I'm actually going to regret this if it's not got a key and it doesn't have a key. Key!
That might have been wiser.
We're going to have to sadly skip our item room, it appears, but we got a second
lifeline with holy mantle. That is an unfortunate pill to swallow. Maybe I can get a key out of
any, a key, a coin out, oh, there we go. We are going to pick up phd, so it means we can swallow pills.
Something's wrong. Okay, now you have to play it. I'm not, I don't know. Okay, okay, okay.
Hopefully this is, this. Okay, it looked like a secret. Oh, what? What? Right.
That's why I didn't want to happen. And there's a secret room!
Oh, I'm so scared. Oh my god. Oh my god, is this the run?
Is this the run?
Is this the run? We got blank card on tainted lost with holy card in our freaking holster.
Oh, please don't fuck it up. I'm going to be so sad. I'm going to be so sad if I fuck this up.
I'm going to camp on the rock. I know. Okay, we can, we can take a devil deal. It's fine.
Curious. Oh no, it's goat head. My apologies, it's goat head. Absolutely, absolutely on goat
head. Okay, so we can choose now.
Okay, I am so scared. The code, papa, vector, hotel, foxtrot,
New Guinea. What's it? November, echo, wanker, November. I hardly even know.
I am so scared to progress. I don't not want to lose this run. I feel like I'm going to be dumb
and use the card or something. Can, holy mantles can't stack, can they? I can't stack this holy
mantle card. I've never had the combo before. Okay, sorry. They can't stack. Okay.
Sorry, I just got a little nervous. Sorry. I lost my cool a little bit.
Okay. Okay, now I just need some good combos to put my damage up so I can one shot stuff as soon
as I enter the room. Is that too much to ask for? To one shot stuff, huh?
Not this room, not this room. It's so small. Okay. Okay, hold it. Cards can't stack, but
consider this. I am MLG pro. Shot speed up. Okay. Okay. I'm analising the contents, not really
speaking to me. I don't know where to go. I feel it. Yeah, I was going to say, I feel like this is
the way to the boss. Okay, easy, easy. Take out any. It's not small. It's just cool. You lost your
cool. I lost my cool. Oh, wait, shit. Oh, my soundboard isn't up. Right. Sorry. I need to try
hard. Forget the soundboard. This might actually be the run. This might actually be the run. I'm just
from afar, nice and safe. If I could get contact to protect me.
Ah, right, okay. Okay, okay. What's in here?
Moves along. Enemies are attracted to the fly. Okay, this is good. Oh, that's why it's called
lost fly because it takes away the attention from lost. I know there's a tinted rock here,
but we don't take any so hard. I don't think we're going to raid Toshiba on time. Oh, no.
Don't the whole point. Oh, don't thank you. Right, okay. Let me get up, let me get up.
Nice and steady. Use her.
Well, we just turned back into the boss. I don't know. These spectral tears are so good early on.
Okay, he's attacking him, so I'll do that. No, no.
We're not. Key. I was too late for that on the other side of the map now.
Right, holy car, do not dare use right bumper or I will eat your face.
Okay, well, I was a waste. Don't do that again. I believe Mercy is going to be the one responsible
for the POV. Okay, okay, okay. Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I can do this. Well, the odds of the secret room being right here are pretty high.
Yeah, what we got? Rubbage, right.
Oh, no, I'm not getting an item.
Unless it, well, if it's another, oh, he's attacking the fly. Thank goodness.
Okay, 50%. He might, yeah, I was going to say he might swap the flies out of range now.
Yep, that's okay. Perfect will.
Cube and meat. Lamal. Cube and meat. We take perfection. I mean, we can fly over to items.
Well, sure. And pop it. Well, there's no point in popping it, but we could maybe get
bookworm or whatever it's called. Oh, stress, stress, stress, stress.
They are making Shrek 5. Better not. Thank you, but meat. Well, if it turned into meat boy,
meat boy goes away and attacks, which wouldn't go amiss.
Why are you a patch?
Okay, these are the diagonal guys, so we're just going to stay nice and steady.
Breathe and hydrate, bro, honestly. I'm so stressed right now. My blood pressures through
the roof. My ears must be red from how stressed I am right now. Okay, we've got lucky penny,
so if we pick up any kind of staticy effect, as long as we don't get walloped,
I couldn't have made that closer if I desired.
I couldn't have made that any closer if I had the desire to. I would like to find the shop, please.
No. Let's go to this one for that. He can't come over yet.
Oh, I do have a key.
Yeah, 11% luck. I'm going to need you to start dropping pickups because I'm starting to not
think it's 11% luck. I need range as well. I need to be able to safely attack from like halfway
across the room. A bomb? A bomb's not key though. Can you say key? Right, I'm going to push them
into the fly on purpose. I could have easily gotten hit by that. I'm not going to lie.
Okay, he's rejecting key. Right, I'm not laughing anymore video game. I'm getting stressed.
I'm getting stressed. Okay, we have a key. It's a golden one, so we don't have to sacrifice any key we obtain.
Why is this map so long? I almost just backed into that. I almost just backed into that. I'm
not even kidding. Oh, I saw it. The pointy rock in the corner. I am playing so safe. You have no idea.
I'm trying to range up the exact thing I needed. Hallelujah.
The game may sometimes deliver.
Automatically charges and fully charges the active item. Okay, I'll just pick it up now.
So we can get it even more common. Yeah, this is definitely a bomb run and not any other kind of run.
I'm stressed. The blood, if I had a heart rate monitor on right now, it is not going to blow
on 120. Right, we're going to turn back and we're going to go to the item room.
I love how you can actually do it in pencil. It's so much
big. Just ask Johnny. It seems like, how about work? Fly is putting in work. The fly is taking
all of the aggro when we enter a room, which is really, you know, that's such a shame. Yeah,
the game is like, oh yeah, you get good items. The items in the game. Butt bombs, top blasts.
Okay, thanks, I guess. That's just an average day for me, if I'm being honest. Butt bombs.
I love how this began as a demonstration of why lost runs are so hard and then you get a god run.
The pressure is getting worse, so I feel like I'm going to mess it up really badly,
which is a shame, but it's kind of on par for me. So I wouldn't be too surprised.
Wouldn't be surprised at all. Oh, I don't like that. I don't like that. Thank goodness that
fly took the aggro for those spaky guys. Wow. Breathe. I'm so scared.
I'm going to be sick. I'm actually going to be sick in this run.
A quarter or a backstab. I'm going to go with a backstab.
Oh, I'm so stressed. What other items do you need? Everything. Just everything.
We're on floor five. One more and then we do mam.
Curse of the blinds. So we don't know what item we're going to pick up, but thankfully
I made it home. You're alive. You didn't die. Thank you for the tip, Rolly legends.
Oh, not good, not good, not good, not good. I am so lucky I held back those bullets there.
Come on. Come on, just die. You're not even a champion.
I feel sick to my stomach from worry.
Everyone wants a gamer girlfriend until she throws up on Isaac because she's got a really good last run.
Okay, we're going to get money from this fight. We know that there's not a greed's fight in the
shop, so it is worth her here. Oh, my stomach is actually twisting and nervousness. Bro, calm down,
relax. It's just a video game. If it's just a video game, then why does it make me so happy? Win, win.
Her palms are swayed. They are freaking, oh, we got another range.
Oh, this cannot be true. And yet it is my eye. Oh, it's the jumpy ones. It's the ones I don't like.
They've got blood on their front. That means they're a jumpy one.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
Oh, my, I'm not kidding. My guts are genuinely twisting, bro.
Okay, take your time. Take your, use your, you can
know again, Hunter. I kind of still want perfection. Whoa, we got planetarium. No way.
If I lose, you have to comfort me unironically, Ruth, and that's so mean. Putting that pressure
on me. We got planetarium. Please be political or like something or Venus or take Venus.
Oh, God. Mars. What does Mars do? I don't know what Mars does. I've never had it before. What does
Mars do? GG run. Wait, why? What does it do? Double tap the move button.
This is getting wet. What? Double tap the move button.
Nothing's happening. Mars is bad. Of course, I get the only one thing that's bad.
Double tap, move in the same direction.
What? I have a ram. I have a ram. What's wrong with ram? Am I going crazy?
Okay, we're better chests. I'll take it. Wait, what's the
one point? It lets you dash, but it works weird.
Oh, that's so lucky to fly, honestly.
Short speed. Flight for the room. No, we need holy mantle. Don't tempt me.
We already have flight. We're the loss.
And before I die via mimic chest, I wouldn't put that past me.
Okay, that's fine.
Well, we have mum's keys. We actually don't need that.
Oh, no. These guys will charge across the map. I am letting distance do the rest.
You can use it to go in the curse room. I am not risking like that. I am not good enough for that.
Right, we've got the planetarium. We've got everything along the way. Okay.
Monster 2.0.
I don't like it. Okay, he's focusing on the fly, though. I'll take it. If you want to charge the
fly, I was going to keep up with the fly. Oh, this is fantastic for aggro.
Oh, this is fantastic. Oh, farted, sorry. Excuse me.
We need to get poisoned. They got poisoned by Mayukas. Mayukas.
Buy a bow here, ladies and gentlemen. Buy a bow here.
Oh, right, aggro. He's got aggro.
Well, okay, I understand the problem now with Mars.
I did not do that. I understand the problem with Mars.
I understand the problem with Mars. I don't know what it is, but I'm taking it. It's free.
Okay, we've got a guppy's hairball, sure. Mars is very bad. I agree. I agree, I agree, I agree.
Lost fly is good. Right, we're doing the first mum fight.
It's like we have hardly any damage.
Someone.
All right, no mimic chest. What was that? Short speed? That looks like it.
Take your time.
Oh, that's in here.
Oh, that's kind of worth it if I don't fuck up.
Kind of worth it if I don't mess it up.
I think I'm going to have to do it. I do. Okay, okay, okay.
What? You moved me. Please focus on that fly above you.
Please. The fly. Oh, okay.
Okay, the poison damage is, I don't know. Did we do it?
Okay. No, no, no, no, no, no. The fly. The fly. Look at the fly. No, Mars, please.
How did you even do that? I was looking above.
Oh my gosh. Oh, all right, we've got damage. That's all. Okay, I'm luck. Okay, I'll take it.
I'm going to be sick. Anonymous. Thank you. You didn't say anything in your message. Thank you,
though. I will take that as your silent support of this run. This most stressful encounter. I'm
going to have to tell my dad to stop doing whatever he's doing. I'm actually about to talk.
It's fine. We're okay. We're okay. Relax, relax, relax, relax, relax. Okay,
marked. I don't like marked. That's shit. Okay. That's right. Just look at the fly.
Mimic chest. The fly is so delicious, isn't it? My heart just jumped. It's fine. We have a holy card
and we have the card repeater. Curse of the maze strikes again. Curse of the maze wasn't supposed
to put us in here, but okay. We already have it back. Thankfully, we also have voltage or
whatever it's called. I'll just forget the name between them both. Relax, relax, relax. Safety,
safety, safety, safety, safety, safety, safety, safety. I'm not sure what we would benefit in an
arcade. Hell, maybe. Give us our item room. I am, yeah, I was purposely-
Oh, my heart is jumping. Speed. I'll take speed. That can get us away from the enemy.
Okay. I can pick all these up. That's fine. Check it was in the shop. A greed bait. That's fine.
Okay. Okay, absolutely wait for me. That damage upgrade? Fantastic. I'll take 12 more of them,
please. I'll have 14 more. Right. Okay. So greed can no longer appear in shops because we dealt with
greed and super greed. So now for the boss. Right, we're going to check out the arcade. I have plenty
of money to go around. No. But thank you though. But no thanks. Okay, we're just going to gently
make our way, Mosey, our way back to the boss fight. Now, this is ma'am. Oh, it's the end, isn't it?
It's the last shop. Oh, you're right. I don't realize how fast we're going through it. Not me going
faster in this mode than like actually playing a regular cane run. Okay. Okay, okay. That's fine.
Wow, we are so interested in that one fly, aren't we? Oh, we love that one fly. Thank God I have
the mod that lets me actually see when she's stomping down. Mars, not now.
Not now, Mars.
I was really hoping for a Pluto because we could get such a small hitbox with Pluto.
We did it. What are we taking though? What's the question? Enjoying, sure.
What are we taking? Damage?
Invincibility. That was cat. Damage. Taking damage at half a red heart and none. Damage. Okay, the
negative. 7.61, that was good. That was good, right. Hold it together,
refling. Hold it together. I'm very nervous. Yeah, I don't even have one unlock on him.
Just, I'm going to use a lot of rocks for cover and stuff like that.
Or moam down like that, that's also an option. I'm going to pick up all I can. If we get like
beggars, I'm just going to give it to them. They might be able to this.
Assist us.
I am so sorry if I seem like such a tryhard. It's because I am tryharding.
Please follow the fly, not me, the fly.
Okay, take your time. That was naughty. That was very naughty.
Oh my god, my dad's gone for a piss.
The toilet's right outside my door.
All right, let's try that again, shall we? There's a shame we didn't get more pills. You
know that should have bought the pills in the shop. I just think I was paying enough attention.
That's on me. Oh, that's on me. That was my mistake.
You first. You next. Just take your time. We've got, time is on our side, okay?
Where there's no timer, there's no rush. We just need to find the boss room.
I'm fine. I'm not just randomly singing out terrifying fear. Okay, that's fantastic.
We're going to see if there's a, oh, there you go.
I just realized that thing splattered and could have got us.
What the hell, Shrek 5 is real. Are you guys trolling me right now in the middle of this
very intense game? Please look at the fly. The fly, yes, the fly. The fly. Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, are we going to do it? Size down, hit box smaller. I repeat, hit box smaller.
Hit box, stop, Marshmars. I was going to say Marshmallow. No.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Okay, that's fine. Okay, holy cards. We'll have everything. Okay.
All out for head. Yeah, Shrek 5 is in production. It's almost enough, so.
You really deserve a cola. I will, I am going to lie down after this one. I can tell you that much.
Gamer instinct. Where is the boss? Top left. Okay, gamer instinct. Don't let us down.
Now again, we have spectral tears. We will use rocks to our full advantage.
Okay.
Oh, that's okay, Marsh. You were allowed to do that when I'm not in a fate,
but when I'm in a fate, Marsh, no, Marsh, that's naughty. You're a naughty boy, Marsh. You know,
I didn't want you. You know, I wanted you to be Pluto. Shit. Please do not fuck up in this room.
Okay, yeah, let's go for the day. Yes, yeah, let's go for the...
See how there was a flat wall and all the enemies spawned right side? Do not tear or touch that.
Okay. Okay, okay. Sorry, I am tryharding out the Wazoo. I'm not even pretending.
We could do Gambo, but we don't have a beggar, so there's no point. I'm telling you,
do it on purpose. I will fly it in your boot, too.
I don't want to break these rocks. These rocks can break into splatters. I might actually hurt
myself. I know. Go away. Oh, gamer instinct. Oh, my gosh, gamer instinct. They can fly,
they can fly. They fly now. They fly now. They fly now. Okay, okay, to get it.
Yeah, he could fly a couple of episodes back, but it's fine. He'll let us sleep.
No, I could only be, like, if it wasn't here, I could only be there.
Oh, no, I messed up. I messed up. I messed up.
Oh, go for the fly. Go for the fly. We love the fly. We love casting spells. Shadow Wizard,
yeah. Mars saved me. Mars, I judged you too quickly. Forgive my ignorance,
for I did not know what I was judging. I love you, Mars. We love the planet. We love the red
planet. We love the iron-ice planet. Oh, that's fine. It's fine.
Wait, on half a heart or less, I assume that counts right now. Surely that counts right now.
Oh, okay, okay, we're in the money. Not as being able to do hush, absolutely not, right?
We took the negative, we must go down. We must stay focused. Yay, now you're all...
Babylon works. Okay, gamer instincts. Bottom right, gamer instincts, bottom right.
Shh, you know what? I've had a lot of gamer instincts today. Let's try that again. I meant
to say right, right, it's for gamer... Okay, hold on. We can take these. Yes, please. Range,
speed, sure. Something's wrong. Short speed, absolutely. Power pill, no.
Okay, please do not whip me through the rock. I would appreciate that.
Do we want to be max speed? I don't know if we actually want to be max speed,
because it gets very slippery. No, no, no, no, no, no, focus on the fly, the fly, the fly.
Oh, are you ranged? Yep, I want to shoot from halfway across the room.
If I'm correct, about right side gamer instinct.
I am wrong. Okay, go for the thing, go for the thing, not me, go for the fly. Go for the fly!
The fly! Go for the fly! Oh, what was the secret room, though? Because why would it be,
no. Okay, it's top right. I was close. Okay, do not roll over any rocks that have spikes in them.
What are you and why are you that colour?
No secret room, secret room above? Okay, these rooms are getting odd, though.
Stay in the rocks, shiver me timbers. My timbers have been shivered.
Oh, in the rock. Oh, laser beam! I did not even see that laser beam, that was so lucky.
I did not even see that beam. I'm happy with my trinket, I will not be tempted.
He doesn't go away. Okay, that's fine. He doesn't have to go away, okay.
Gamer, oh no, it's the Satan fight, okay. Gamer instinct, go for the fly. No Mars, not now.
Okay, they're going for the fly, I'm happy. Okay, Satan, go for the fly, go for the fly,
go for the fly, Satan, go for the fly, Satan, go for the fly, go for the fly. We love,
we love going for flies. Yes, good, Satan. Now, the last fight, go for the fly,
go for the fly, the fly. We love the fly, we love the fly, we, we lost fly.
Oh, God, are we doing it? Can we do it? Can we do lamb on tainted?
Oh, we can take nothing, can we take anything from here? I don't know how it works,
can we take anything? We have Athene, I've never had Athene.
Can I take one thing from here? Take one, I am, take brimstone, okay, I trust you.
Okay, shit. Oh, it's homing, I have homing, I forgot.
I forgot we had homing. Oh, what, there's three? I thought there was two.
Two. Mars, not now, buddy.
I have a sore stomach because I'm gaming so hard.
Stop, look at the fly, look at the fly, we love the fly.
How I did not lose anything there. Oh, the fly, please.
Okay, okay, the fly. No, do not give me bombs.
Oh, consecutive tier hits, yes sir. The fly.
You know you want to take that, Gro, I almost just walked into him and substituted my holy mantle.
Oh.
Tears can bounce, can brimstone bounce on these cheeks? I'm asking for a friend, can brimstone bounce?
Oh my gosh, where is it? Is it bottom left?
It's either left up or down left, so strong I can hear that.
So strongly I heard the stream is pre-recorded one or counter that.
I read it before your thing loaded, get right, that's how it's not pre-recorded.
It's not what we want, but it's okay, thank you for your submission.
Okay, that's right, like that, the fly is getting, oh, wow, wow.
Thank you Broly legend for the tip, I'm so sorry.
Nope, we're absolutely not, proof that this is pre-recorded confirmed.
That's not, how, oh no, okay, he's gonna be occupied with that fly.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, okay, it has to be left side.
I don't, I don't think I want that, I don't know, you guys will tell me if I should take it or not.
Okay, will you guys tell me if I need that?
Inner eye, decreases my fire rate, Isaac shoots three tears at once though.
Triple shot is good, slower shot but three.
Doesn't give you triple brimstone, I have no idea.
I have wall bouncing as well.
Let's find out, is it wall bounce, oh okay, it like fully wall bounces.
Oh wow, okay, wow, wee wee wow.
Oh, I missed that shot, that's okay.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Oh, and we got a fricking unbelievably, we got that back, unbelievably, I can't believe that.
I do believe, but it happens so I believe it, I believe.
Spiders do not give contact damage.
Now, hear me out, we go back and try and pick up as much items as possible or do you think we can do it?
Did we just go for it or did I go back and pick up as, wait, you say pre, if I unlock delirium,
you're right, if I unlock delirium we have to send it for delirium, so I'm going to try and unlock everything.
Perfect, we're gonna, we might get delirium, okay,
and if we do, I want to be as ready as I can be.
Mars, you are so cheeky.
You're a cheeky boy Mars and you know exactly what you're doing, giving me a heart attack.
Okay, bombs, sure, poison immunity, a chance for a random direction, sure, I'll absolutely take that, are you joking?
What we got, what we got?
Invincibility, every six frames,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
We pray for delirium, we pray for delirium, I can't believe I'm asking for delirium, but I am, no,
no, no, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, not a good pick up.
There might be a secret room here but I don't know, I don't know,
maybe here, there you go, no, room, room, delirium doesn't close when you exit the room,
I didn't know that, hello, okay,
come on, Mr. Fly, it's the lost fly versus lamb, it's nothing else, oh, he's like literally synced on
tom, oh, he's synced on tom, he can't get enough, oh my god, no delirium, no delirium,
drop, no delirium, okay, we did it though, that's my first fucking win, let's go, gee,
motherfucking gee, wait, oh, you liar, you liar video game,
am I getting the unlocks, I'm not getting achievements,
there they are, I know we're not playing hard mode, I don't care, I'm number one on this one,
okay, delirium, I'm coming for you buddy, I don't know where you are but let's go for it,
now you do get boss items by doing boss room so we could upgrade our current stash,
spiders don't hurt us, let's go,
oh, can we do delirium as a question, Mars, stop, you naughty boy,
sure, sure, how do it, oh, come on,
oh, come on, where's the first boss fight, right, we've got one here,
okay, school x, not to be confused,
I mean, at this point does keys make a difference, not really, might as well just take them,
he could maybe give us a guffy from a red chest if he were to drop one,
okay, so unfortunately our first item didn't give us anything good but that's okay,
we're just playing it nice and safe, take that key,
okay, okay, nice and safe,
is that a boogie, no I don't want some boogie, thank you though,
that's a lot of items, keys, oh I could have given it to him,
didn't take that far, hey did oh, surely I'm just blasting this to oblivion, stream,
oh, respawn though, what happens if you respawn, don't be shy, respawn some more,
drain's all short speed,
wait, keys, you want to take that key, oh no, it's one of these rooms, is it,
it's one of these rooms,
I can chase them around the room, oh thank you buddy, look there's more keys for you if you want
them, what are you thinking, you want this key too, no, you shy, okay, you don't have to,
you don't have to give me keys all the time, it's fine, oh no, okay, another new chest,
okay, okay more money, thanks mate, more key, oh, oh I do like bird food, but can I do it,
can I do it, I've no got two trinket slots, unless, do I, I don't know, I'll go back, oh sorry,
I was gonna hand it to him physically, after the holy chest it just stops items, I wish I had freaking
another slot for dead bird because that's like another player on the map really,
able to, anyways, I start to bless them, I am sweeping, that cannot be a secret room,
okay, no key, okay, oh, just mild stress with delirium,
shumer goes to hospital for a heart attack due to playing the lost on Isaac, that'd be quite the
headline, my stomach's sore, my heart isn't sore, but my stomach's sore, it's twisting,
out of nervousness, that could have gone terribly wrong, I'll remember there's a
arrow in here, but there's not too much I can do with it, come on, oh wow, I'd shot too late,
or early hover, don't do that to me, my heart can't take it, mimic chest, now's not the time to show up,
now is not the time for mimic chest to show up, do I make myself clear, arrange up,
full health, full mapping, okay, now we can use this to our advantage,
if we go down we can get to boss, we can get boss fights that aren't delirium confirmed,
did I almost just walk into a chest though, I almost did it wrong, okay, we can
take this, keep her sat,
I mean it's too late now, I'm sorry,
keep taking his weakies, I'm sorry, I don't mean it, I promise I'm doing it on purpose buddy,
which is very low IQ right now, okay there, take it,
right, this one can't be delirium,
I'll take that, are you joking, all stats up, I'll take that, right, what one can't be delirium,
I mean it's unlikely it's this one, it looks like the top left is delirium,
down is free, gentle, what do we get, a bane, I don't want a bane,
which one, it looks like that left one, like if you look where I'm literally
standing in the game on the map, I think that one's delirium, I mean this one
and the one over there, right, we'll go up for now because I don't think the one up is delirium,
sack and sausage, I don't even see that, I'll take that, are you joking,
okay, no keys for you this time buddy, sorry,
okay, a blast assist, okay, down left is free, okay and then delirium is where I think he is on
the map, sure bottoms why not, then yeah we've got one more boss to walk by and then it's delirium,
oh boy, I hope because we are smaller,
we are gonna be okay, yeah for a second, yeah, I hope because we are smaller, our hitbox does not
right just, okay,
okay, that was dangerous, oh there's pins, okay that was lucky,
okay, oh right,
how much more OP can I get, I've come on a smaller hitbox, let's go,
ooh, oh you're so funny like that delirium, you think I didn't see silly sausage, I don't
know exactly where you are, you think I don't have the skill, the intellect, the foresight
to know what's going on with you Mr. Delirium, do you think I do not know these things, your
crafty ways, your terrible reign against poor Isaac that you have, the grasp that the boy cannot seem
to undo, stop it delirium, you're upsetting me, I'm one shot, no well I have a Hail Mary,
you're upsetting me delirium, no more will you harm the child known as Isaac,
the boy will no peace, he will ascend without you,
did I do it,
did I do it, I did it, I unlocked ghost bombs,
I did it, oh my god,
oh I don't, that's not registered, I did that, I just did that, my first ever look like tainted lost,
oh my god, that's not registering,
what did I say about this stream being squitted being pre-recorded and that you would win your
first lost run on stream, I think maybe you need to comfort me instead of the other way around
for all the denial, now be a good girl and come cuddle me, oh my god, what just happened,
thank you so much, anonymous, you never even said anything, thank you tiny spiny for the tip,
anonymous, congratulations, take my super chat cherry, I think I took it twice,
did you mean to do that twice, thank you domino mickey, I'm thinking, congratulations,
take my super chat cherry, I can't believe I did that, our hands are sweating, I'm like ringing my
hands right now, I'm so nervous, money duplication glitch, thank you, yeah thank you for the money
duplication, oh my gosh, thank you anonymous, oh my god, we did that, we have ghost bombs,
oh, we unlocked ghost bombs,
well I don't know where they'd be but I assume somewhere near the end,
you're so good, no that was luck, literally we started with homing, the spin is the only reason
I could do that run, the spoon is the only reason, scrawny has humbling bundle in real life, okay
that's actually really good, ghost bomb for ghost bomb, you have to take them up to have them appear
twice, might have said in before at the start the run that died on the second room doesn't count,
thank you no alessandro, we did it, amazing performance, I don't know how I did that,
ghost bombs, I don't know where they're hiding but they're somewhere here,
I can't believe that, that's absolutely amazing, there, there you are Mars, I could have rolled
anything else, radiant victory, the moon's blessing, so secret rooms, mercury speed up,
you feel elusive so I'm super fast, venus, I have charm effect, born of rock destroy stuff,
one more run, this is a rare chance to get created by mercy, no I'm redirecting to mercy now,
thank you so much, don't sit down with it, I can't believe that, oh my goodness, thank you
juke lucifuge, that's not how you say it, how the fuck do you say that, juke lucifuge, is that how
you say it, fudge, thank you for the 50 gifted memberships, broly legend, because of Mars, Mars
did actually help me, right let me redirect into mercy, my goodness, I can't believe that,
that's not sunk in yet, that just happened, now there's a thing called streamer luck, I do not
know what I just experienced, congrats to those who caught it with your face, enjoy the emotes,
there's more emotes coming very shortly, there's a batch of 13 emotes coming,
I can't believe that, that's not sunk in, right mercy, save, okay mercy's confirmed to be redirected
into, thank you again juke lucifuge, that's not how you say it, I'm sorry, lucifuge,
for the 50 gifted memberships, that was 100 gifted memberships of stream, thank you Emmanuel
copper, he's nuts in my mouth, thank you, that's insane, look at it assigning to people, congrats
on those who grabbed it, my goodness, I need to go have a cigarette after that, bro I need
a cigarette after that, can you pass me one, I'm so sweaty, I'm shaking, I need food in my stomach,
okay, thank you so so much for that miniature endurance streamer, I actually didn't mean to do
that, I'm so sorry dad, ripped out, who's literally in the other room waiting for me to come hang out,
we're off the bunnings to get a snack, it's not sundae is it, right rip, now a good cooked meals,
perfect, yes I get to have a steak to celebrate that, I need to drink water to rehydrate, oh my god,
thank you Miku again for letting me take your super chat cherry, it does feel me both glee being
able to take your cherry, this is 10% luck, 20% skill, 15% concentrated power will, 5% pleasure,
50% pain, 100% reason to remember the name, I forgot about that song until you just mentioned it there,
thank you so much, honestly thank you, 8, I'm gonna redirect into Mersey because lovely Mersey's
currently in a collab so please enjoy it to this full extent, I'm gonna lie down after that,
my heart is palpitating, gg's mother, g, motherfucking g says I throw up my water,
thank you so so much, I will see you goofy gibbers tomorrow, please enjoy Mersey to the fullest,
and she be as well, she's in it and I believe it is Poseidon, and the sun one, which I've forgotten
the name of temporarily, so lie, thank you so much, I'm going to lie down now, and then I'm going to
see you at Bunnings, if you're at Bunnings, hi, right, bye bye, I'll see you tomorrow,
you give me out one big smidge, okay, um, thank you for all this dreamer luck you give me,
you give me out on Boutro, you give me out on T-Boy, you give me out on just everything,
so much luck, bye bye, I see you goofy gibbers tomorrow, say hi to Mersey for me and Chibi,
wow